oh
oh yeah that that's true
that's pretty true yeah that's true
yeah that's that's pretty true
oh i can do it back to him like this
aha you [__] up my friend that was
your mistake
don't know what the [__] that was but
probably was not regulation
probably was cheating i don't want to
throw out blind accusations but um
i didn't i didn't i thought that play
was a little dirty in my mind
in my mind that plays a little dirty and
i don't appre
i don't appreciate people that play like
that
go to your lessons connor andrea didn't
give me any lessons
we were going to but then it didn't work
out
yo can this guy speed the [__] up i have
a match in like six minutes
no not like that broken up with it no no
no no no not like that no no no i mean
like
oh my god um okay if i go here
i can do this take that take the horse
no
hmm ah yes simple really
this is smart watch this
this is this is a smart move here
yes no oh i'm stupid
i thought this i thought this was the
one that could go diagonal i wasn't
paying attention
oh that was dumb of me
you son of a [__] you son of a [__]
go down [__] i dare you
dude this is [__] man
yo way i would [__] you chess hero746
kiss my ass man [__] you
dude [__] you
man i gotta i gotta play smart music
hold on
[__] that guy dude see me irl
bro see what would happen on the
chessboard irl that's all i'm saying
um here we go
[Music]
ah hey connor chess is he on their
channel right now can you just
not not sure if you can swear or not
oh i love chess
i'm good at it um let's just play again
[Music]
oh i i guess i lost again
i don't really okay i don't really know
what just happened
um
did i lose my elo
[Music]
wait what okay there we go
i gotta turn down this music it's too
loud in my ear
it's stressing me out frame one loss
yeah
okay stick to what i know
i'm pulling out the connor horse is what
they call this
they call this move the connor horse
it's a bold play they don't teach you
this one in school
hmm
quiet music must focus
[Music]
i do that
like this
take it take it with the horse [__]
take it
wait no wait no i don't like that oh
[__]
wait what do i do here
i feel like i've lost all my chest skill
in a matter of a week
two quick ones i already know i'm
getting there on the perfect line
eat what do i do
back at it again with the white vans i
believe in you mr pants
you hit resign dude i know the chess
channels watch me right now like who the
hell invited this guy
um i'm gonna do
they are gonna get my queen aren't they
they're gonna get the queen
that's extremely unfortunate that is not
ideal
that is just not ideal at all
no don't do it oh
dude not cool
dude here on twitch we call that weird
champ man
i'm not sure how you do it on chess.com
but
around here that's a yikes from me
all right ballsy play here
no
yes
ninja proof demo yeah kuna
thank you for the reason uh oh oh i'm on
the clock again oh
no
stop playing blitz
this is not what i'm supposed to play
ooh outplayed outplayed by a better
player
oh
[__] i had him in the end
i had him in the end all right let's
just go to
what is it live chess yeah
my game should pop up here right
i'm gonna move my cam down here this
time so you guys can see the full chess
board
and so chess.com has a good picture of
me
bottom right busta
not drinking alcohol i drink water
no longer drink alcohol i've resigned
from the bottle
um did they message me my game is like
right now right
or am i the one that is wrong
yeah august 30th at 1 pm pdt i got it i
know what i'm i'm right
i'm good
i know what i'm about i don't miss my
chess match
i don't do that other streamers may miss
their chess match but not your streamer
is beautiful
excuse me what kind of airpods do you
have
they're just earpods actually
believe it or not they're just normal
earpods
ex-wife is back don't worry less oh
that's uh
there she is hey andrea connor keeps
smashing me about lessons like two hours
before commentary
that's not true don't tell them that
don't tell them i'm irresponsible
that's not true
no no that's andrea that's not alexander
alexandra schlatt's girlfriend
i have to take off my glasses
connor's irresponse wow
wow
wow mods can you ban this person please
you ban botez in the chat
accept my friend request on chat
no
literally i woke up not kidding like an
hour ago and
the first few hours of my day were spent
waking up
and like every time i would wake up i'd
message andrea
i wake up two hours later because she
responded like five minutes later
but i went to sleep like five minutes
later so it didn't matter because i
didn't see it
and then
[Music]
so
trainer cocoona
trainer again and venusaur wait we're in
the game we're in the game
oh [__] juice licker
i don't know dude don't know what to do
mike is throbbing
did
[Music]
that's what you are because no matter
what you do box box i will
destroy you oh no no no
no and it's too soon
it's too soon hikaru we didn't even
reach a climax
[Music]
hello everyone and we are back for
another amazing day of
pogchamps how are you guys doing today
donya
and andrea well i'm doing great i'm
super excited we got a marquee match up
here um could not think of a better way
to spend
my sunday uh when it is sunday right yes
i think it is
nice nice i don't even know what day of
the week it is anymore andrea
how are you doing i feel that that
streaming schedule i didn't know what
day was either but i'm definitely
feeling
pumped it's gonna be some fun matches
i'm looking forward to it
lots of my students competing today so
it'll be a good day oh tell me more
which of your students are playing today
so
hafu is going to be playing xqc like
round three later hopefully he wakes up
and then we have
connor taking on um wagga
round one so wait wait wait yeah
yeah sorry so he you know he's doing his
last minute prep
taking a very seriously um been putting
him in many
hours um he's been training his whole
life just for this match actually
also of course his entire career
everything
exactly it's essentially come down to
this sunday he's been playing lots of
imessage
checkers um yep oh i missed speakers
all right yeah this is perfect way to
practice for chess you know but
by playing checkers the superior version
of chess of course
exactly let me note that down that's
yeah that coaching method i
i'm gonna incorporate it yeah i asked
him how his training was going and he
sent me a photo a screenshot of sending
checkers to schlatt so that was what i
got
oh okay well we do have kickoff
here um between half thor and connor
um with hoffler in white for the first
round and we already see some
very exciting stuff happening in the
center we got knight takes e5 followed
by knight takes e4
you know totally symmetrical pawn
structure totally symmetrical position
too um except you know the pieces are
i really ain't got each other's kings
they're they're going
this type of opening wow connor must be
trying something new with a symmetrical
opening i don't think it's the best yet
but he must have run out of ideas or
something
yeah the problem with copying your
opponent is at some point um there
follows something called a check and
here bishop takes f7 check
could not be followed by bishop takes f2
check unfortunately that is
uh not uh a law-abiding move
chess 2.0 thor missed it okay
lord is trying to defend after now conor
actually
has some good moves but we will see
whether he will find them
it's a tricky move queen e2 right
because if black takes on f2 with track
you know the knight on e4 is gonna be
loose
so i think this game is gonna be decided
literally in the next three moves
maybe in the next yeah maybe maybe
yeah i mean it all depends on what
black's able to find here right if he
finds the right move then there's a
fighting chance but every other move is
not looking too
good i'll be even proud if he finds
bishop takes f2
because that is an attacking move okay
yeah i had a feeling
but he's defending he's definitely
knight c6 or knight f7 i mean i think he
sees the discover check but will he find
the right
um way to kind of put it into effect
yeah it's good it's a discover attack
you know i've i've coached
thor a little bit not not a lot just
just once but i
i do think that he is a very very um you
know
quiet and slow player he's a very method
methodological
very good calm player yeah very very
calm player
um so he's just you know we can see him
in the cam he's sitting there he's
really thinking about
oh 9x f7 also a really great move yeah
not the best
and the reason is queen e7 but connor
might just move his king away you know
when you're a beginner sometimes you
sort of
you see the most obvious thing only like
you see the check and you say okay i
just have to move my king
it can be hard to find a way to block
the check but even after queen e7 of
course white wins
the rock on a on he sees and he finds it
okay
i mean conor's definitely been making
some progress in his previous games he
didn't
really try to defend anything here at
least he's been defending
pretty well for his level i think we
have andrea to thank for that
amazing coach well i don't wanna i don't
take too much credit here you know
well i mean unfortunately we do see
um conor dropping the wreck on h8
uh there was not much that black could
have done in that position
so hopefully you know connor is able to
pick up the night later because it's a
little bit trapped there but
not looking very very good for
right and the queen's off the board as
well which which of course is in white's
favor simplification always good when
you're up in cereal
or the king i like it you know
activating the king in the end game
these players they really they know some
principles um really fast learners it's
it's really nice to see
definitely um and you know flora has
actually been practicing chess for a
while i think
even before this the podcast ii was
announced he was already practicing chat
he really does enjoy the game and it's
it's really like you know fun
to see do you guys want to listen in he
just had a very dramatic facepalm
i'm curious what he's thinking let's do
it let's do it
so tell you my [__] piss of what i'm
doing
he's molding a little bit despite having
a great position i know i don't know why
he's molding
i think he has just very high standards
for himself right
only upper rook after eight moves not
good enough
oh
all right very very calm very calm let's
put some music on guys
i was going to be up at night as well
yeah
well i mean conor was on the right track
trying to trap that knight
just his king really had has no way
to finish this plan but it was a good
attempt
some jams on all right
well this might be uh you know looking a
little bit rough for connor
might not go um this might not be his
best game but
the opening these kind of openings where
the start of it is just
something unexpected always ends up in
these kind of situations for people who
haven't played that much trust before
that's exactly right and the open center
you know when the center is this wide
open
that means there's a lot of tactics and
and there's the potential to
to lose a lot of pieces like there we go
nemo did say she doesn't think it's his
best game but genuinely i think it
is his best game even going into this
match i don't think he set a chance
against thor
but he's finally defending his like
developing his pieces the right
direction
other games he would only develop on the
side of the board um and he would
he found some defensive moves he tried a
plan with his king
so i see some progress we'll look on the
bright side
all right like andrea's enthusiasm
indeed indeed but i i am impressed with
thor's
play even in the last three or four
moves you know d3
opening up the pieces bringing the king
out into the end game it's so clear that
he has done
the due diligence he knows those
principles and uh it's really showing
yeah even though he's so disappointed
i've never seen somebody more
disappointed with himself
up a rook into peace i don't understand
that
he's probably like i didn't win that
queen i should have won that queen or
something like that right
chuck made him in three moves ah
unfortunate unlucky but i mean a rook
and a
knight and a pawn is basically the same
value as a queen so you know he did get
what he wanted
hey so you know it's not that bad if our
fourth half thor here
it's really not that bad yeah so now the
bishop hanging the pawn on b7 hanging
although that's
well that's not the biggest fish oh okay
okay so hail tall style
how many pieces is connor going to have
at the end of this game is
yeah he can get a little bit worried
here but he's captured upon
and he's ruined white spawn structure
you don't understand this is
that's true three pawn islands to two
hmm
i don't think white will be able to thor
will definitely be disappointed at that
yeah all right rook comes up
it's looking the classic rook lift that
we see okay
there's signs of brilliance here i mean
he just needs to put these things
together but
but this is something yeah he's
definitely on to something like a
future checkmate maybe bishop before
and eventually rookie six when that
white light squared bishop is gone go
for checkmate
it came over we got checking right on
the board
connor is looking in that plan i just
know it
i like it um i'm okay well the bishop
you know realistically speaking
as much as we would love to see bishop
before rookie six followed by checkmate
on the board
there's white still has a lot of pieces
that he has to lose before the splendor
right and
i'm worried about that g6 square i feel
like that might be a checkmating square
for thor's knight at some point
yeah like rookie one knight g6 yeah
white is much closer to checkmate
but i mean for now the rook is defending
g6 that's true um
so actually we're like you know black is
three moves out from check me why it's
only two moves out
that's the real win con here that's a
real winning condition
let's see if uh connor follows up on
that rook left you know maybe rook d6 or
or even rook e6 you know okay okay
that that g6 square i'm telling you yeah
he's blocked off it looks like a good
move because he's trying to attack but
he may have doomed himself
well i i'm going to just suggest that
this position might have been
doomed before c6 so you know
c6 is is definitely not i don't know why
you say that you i mean clearly
it was not dude at all he had the
mastermind checkmate plan all along
yeah that's nice rookie one would
threaten the checkmate uh knight g6 i
wonder if thor can spot that
pattern okay uh okay he's kind of
reacted to
the threat or is defending he's playing
very carefully here
methodical i do like it uh we
might see connor develop his knight oh i
did
okay very happy yeah one thing i always
had to mention to him was
don't move your pieces twice if you
haven't moved a
single piece once so maybe this advice
is kicking in
oh he's coming for the checkmate what
did i tell you will
connor prevent it oh well i'm afraid
he'll move his knight again or something
like that yeah he should play g5 right
just avoid the checkmate but um
he'll find i'm just worried you'll play
knight f6 or
or like a random bishop d4 or something
the power bishop deal random move
oh and he does he blunders maiden one
now will force see it or will he get
uh was a very clean game from thor
on the bright side conor made some
progress in his play
that's what we're looking for here so it
wasn't a terrible game
he survived like longer than i thought
oh
all right a lot of faith coming in from
connor's
coach right over here uh from from coach
andrea
but you know connor and half thor
they played a very very short game we'll
see what what happens now with conor
playing white pieces
maybe he'll get a little bit more
initiative out of the opening i feel
like for a lot of these kind of
you know for players just starting out
in chess it's all about the opening
right
like we also saw what happened between
dog dog and tia blade
it's like if you get that kind of attack
going in the opening it's it's almost
over for your opponent immediately
because it's just like what is going on
here yeah and
exactly and you you could look bad when
you're when your position is collapsing
but
that doesn't mean you know conor is you
know this is not
necessarily representative of how well
he can play if he gets a good opening as
you mentioned you
i just feel like his play itself might
also improve
definitely yeah i mean one thing to know
also
i don't know if conor knows an opening
yet as we can see last game he just
copied
everything so now that he's playing
white he's not gonna have that option so
i'm very curious how he's gonna begin
the game
yeah um and we're just waiting for the
next game to start it's going to be
interesting to see if conor can make
a comeback in this upcoming game
yeah i'm probably one e4 um
is to be expected and you know
aggressive opening but aflor is so solid
i'm sure he's put in the work um as to
developing a
a good repertoire for black yeah even e4
i'll be
surprised because i think his only
openings for white have been starting
with his knights first
oh really well then f3 is you know a
perfectly fine opening
absolutely yep now if you move the other
knight
you would want to move the pawns at some
point in the general vicinity of the
first five moves but
all right all right what does conor have
planned
this story this is a complicated
position there's 20 moves and he does
it okay he's changing it up maybe he did
practice something
yeah um do we want to do a quick listen
in
yes to connor's opening
this guy's in play now
oh yeah
and then pull this horsey
right there you've never heard the pool
terminology horsey is now in the game
that's what the horsey says oh
this reminds me of that match between
con uh not connor sorry carson
and um who else was it andrea i'm gonna
get this guy out early this time
all right hear me out my memory is bad
that's all i have to say same here i
can't quite put my finger on it
i don't know how you do that
i don't i don't know what that is
h4 is a commonly you know a super gm
move right you even have emotes for this
holy [__] charles i do and it's
it's become popular to play earlier and
earlier almost moved one i mean
closer to move one you play g5 let's go
so i i think he doesn't know what a
castle we went over this a few times but
he may have forgotten
yeah he definitely doesn't know oh no
andrea
andrea good players don't castle okay
you're right it's not a necessary thing
the rook on h1
is going to deliver the checkmate that
is a fantastic point i like that
optimism
that rook lift and that knight and the
queen are all going to come together
forget i don't think i have any problem
going here yeah you absolutely oh he's
very aggressive i kind of like this
honestly
i do especially if he leaves that knight
on g5 after age six
opening up the h file yeah yeah this is
this might be yeah
he's seriously making some progress like
i think he literally practiced
20 minutes but he's he's getting better
i'm very happy to see
he's improving move by move yes minute
by minute
oh this is problematic all right
explanations
i don't like that he's touched that he's
grabbed his screen because there's
nowhere to put it
fantastic
and now he can trap black's bishop this
is actually a crushing position oh my
god
will he see g4 five head moment dude
big brain saying the right like
come on connor push the g pawn now
you're so close he's almost there
bringing out the master plan click in
that area
oh oh oh oh oh
that's poisoned don't take it no connor
you were doing so well rook f7 well that
was not necessary but still good for
what you're doing
yeah thor is also he must be under
pressure or something
all right well taking back with the
bishop would have been a clean
piece up for black but um i think
hoffler actually
almost pre-moved that he he played that
in like 1.2 seconds and
uh getting jiggy with it look at him
bishop back to h5 is devastating queen
is almost trapped there
but i think thor's gonna take it
yeah the white king is also giving me a
little bit of anxiety being stuck on e1
with
no chances of castling short because of
the bishop on c5
and also very very slim chance of
castling long because there are just so
many pieces in the way
oops is not in connor's plans we have
the checkmate plan
we don't care about our king in this
game he writes something
he's he's trying to go for this pawn i
think uh okay i like this d3
winning the pawn i mean nice there's
elements of good chess in his play
there definitely is um you know we saw a
very
very fast queen eight coming from black
just
using the queen to aim at white's king
which is still stuck in the center
are we going to see a move like d5 um
what is what do you think hawthorne's
plan is with queenie eight
i'm thinking he might be preparing
bishop h5 oh
yep luckily conor has made room for his
queen
so this move is not as effective a few
moves later
there are places for this queen to go
yeah if only if conor knew castling
queenside castle would be
fantastic i mean obviously not possible
not possible anymore later
later it'd be a very safe move
connecting his rooks
and we just have to leave him in the
middle i guess well
now another thing thor could do use that
queen for is to play d5 here
blasting open the center using the fact
that white can't get but i think he's
probably going to bring his night out
first
oh c6 okay so he's maybe preparing d5
but even if you play d5 there are still
chances for you to play e5
definitely
so i'm not sure that is black's best
plan however still
still a very very good plan it's just
you hope that white won't get e5
and d4 push because then the center will
be really strong
um and you won't have a lot of chances
to attack the white king which is still
in the center so you know
when your opponents k oh another rook
left original uplift or right
absolutely reasonable idea yeah why
don't you be coaching
connor this is called him this is all
him
i've been taught him more than those 30
minutes before austin round
so yeah if he'll find
okay i don't want jinx i'm just gonna
stay silent
just gonna say too much and this could
be a brilliant moment
mm-hmm rook g3 now i'm telling you he
will play rook g3
you think he'll play richie right i
think he will i believe
now that that's actually that good but
but it show there we go wow
the prophet is here he's in the house
with one g3 but yeah i mean he if
i don't know if he'd find bishop h6 but
he could have a great attack here
d takes e4 the problem is the position
opens up now it's not the end of the
world white could just capture twice and
tuck the king away on f1
the game continues
um but it's it's a little scary i feel
like
you know not that being
feeling like your king is unsafe it's a
very very common trait
i would say for for beginner players
it's just
oh we weren't ready for that another
positional sacrifice
wait why did he why didn't you expect
that prophet yeah
yeah yeah well it was so brilliant that
i
that i didn't think he had the uh
outside of daniel's level
h6 check and queen g5 let's go he's
going for another mastermind
checkmate yeah he's just playing bishop
h6
king goes back and then we got queen g5
and maybe going queen
to g7 you know what we'll be able to
lift the other rook maybe a4
rook a3 rook b3 and then come to b7
you're right you're right at this point
i don't know what to expect
exactly okay well
oh okay first he said first he opens up
the g
file and then he's gonna get that rook
to g1 exactly usually
when you play this kind these kind of
moves it goes the
other way as in you want to have your
rook behind your pawn before you play g4
rather than have your
rook ahead of your pawns and then give
it up and then play g4 you know
he kind of said that got the ideas
yeah he's almost got the idea he's just
forgetting that you need
pieces in order to execute
exactly exactly you sacrifice all of
them you know
you might not have any left to attack
with yeah
and well this is what i was afraid of
the king is being hit
um not a lot of great places for this
king unfortunately you have what do you
mean
oh sorry sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry my
bad my bad d1 is a beautiful place for
the kids to go
d1 go to sleep one to go all right
perfect i would not want my king
anywhere else on the board
yep that back rank is uh very
comfortable
for white obviously i have i have a bad
feeling he's thinking about covering
this check up which
you cannot do because there's no squares
defended on the e file
yeah um if i if i know his mentality
yeah
yeah just move the king move the king
okay okay
all right yeah unfortunately black gets
another
tempo taking g4 with check but doesn't
have many options
all right it's played and then we'll
gonna probably see king to c1
um after which you know a lot of moves
in this position
are pretty good for black maybe all of
them honestly yeah it's very hard to
find a bad move here
now the position would be probably
unclear if black had blundered his queen
here that's that's an indicator of how
one-sided it is
yeah yeah that is a great point
um being up to two minor pieces right
now
um on blacks on blacks and the king is a
little bit unsafe though you have to
give you have to give conor credit for
that i really want connor to play
bishop h6 but he's not looking for his
forcing moves
you know bishop mage looks to be a
really good move because after king h8
then you play queen g5 attacking the
bishop tonight and check me
okay he's very good aiming for b4 i like
mean
developing the knight to the rim but
specific idea in mind very nice move
yep yep thor is thinking ahead and i've
noticed this about thor's games like
he's actually very good at
involving all of his pieces in the game
which is something that sometimes
beginners can struggle with they forget
about developing the rest of their
pieces
connor never does that conor never does
that yeah he developed i mean
he never forgets about his other pieces
yeah
i mean you know if we see a3 here from
from conor
i would say he deserves a cookie after
that because
prophylaxis yeah prophylactic thank you
you know thinking like harpoff one of
the best players
um in the world a3 would be a great move
here
but but like like we know um this
position is not looking too great for
conor he might also consider
bringing his rick out um as you know
just getting all of your pieces involved
in the position is really important
and after oh exactly okay
on the same page he forgot to sacrifice
the
piece that he really should have
sacrificed the most which is the a spawn
that would have made everything work out
perfectly
yeah i'm not sure what the rick wants to
do on h1 he's looking at his
own pawn but hey look look he's here for
the apocalypse i mean
that's all i could ask for here we're
not asking for oh
oh god okay maybe like paving
there paving the path to g5 for the
queen that's true
the red carpet has been unfurled and now
the decisive invasion of the queen
yeah i mean conor was playing three
checks this was a brilliant sacrifice
yeah even if it was three checks i
wouldn't be so
sure yeah black would have won that game
oh
and another now we're playing all right
all right what are the chances he loses
his rook at the night in the next five
moves as well
and then we see maybe 94
another one bites the dust dude i'm
telling you he's planning stalemate
maybe maybe he just didn't get the memo
this was oh i don't even need it says
thor
yeah that is protein for today he's like
i don't need that rook
enough i'm kind of curious what thor is
listening to
all right let's do it let's take a
listening yeah let's see what he's hear
what he's jamming
oh i wasn't expecting this why is he
shaking his head
he didn't see the rookie positions
[Music]
oh
right that was some good music
now he's nodding instead he's back in
the groove yeah
he remembers he's basically up four
pieces and a queen so yeah
good reminder to keep in mind yeah i
don't think it's that bad even if he
lost his queen here
no checkmate is coming i mean he could
try to sack his knight
and then run to c3 but yeah if we see
king to c1 we have checkmate with bishop
e3
and if he goes king to b3 well
i'm just gonna say that king is is gonna
get checkmated within
within the next few moves that's a
pretty bold prediction true i don't know
yeah i don't know i'm sorry i you know
oh there we go the stalemate strategy
continues
he does not let us down i don't think i
have ever seen
a person up for entire all minor pieces
have been intact and black is up all of
them
together with the queen i just want to
say if hawthorne
like like the with the way hoffler is
playing i feel like he's going to get
that rook too
like he has to go get that wreck go get
it
man this is this has been a rough two
games for conor i'm not going to lie
i mean it's still he made improvement it
was like
i'd say like 0.001 chance he would win
any of these games so
these games are pretty good for what we
could do here
that's true i mean as long as you know
conor is is having fun
he's enjoying the games he's improving
he's learning
he's learning exactly that's all that
matters extract the positive you know
got to see what you
you know you found some ideas just got
to build on that
and uh that's just how you improve for
sure
thor i'm he keeps hovering over squares
where the queen will be blundered i
don't like because you kind of you can
actually
press them i've done that before you
know oh
actually one a couple many years ago um
i had this game where i was playing with
the resign button i like press resign
and you know it can confirm resignation
are you sure you want to design and then
no no of course and i was winning i was
like 10 and of course i accidentally
pressed the resign button and then
accidentally confirmed it
and um so maybe conor will win i mean
yeah maybe through the takeaway is that
conor kent has hopes to win this game
exactly
yeah um there's always that's why i
always tell people to never resign just
never
spilled that day yeah
yeah i i do think that you know honestly
like all jokes aside
it's it's a good practice to not resign
yeah ever basically um especially at
this you know when you're a beginner
right i agree and there goes the rook
by the way all right yeah
okay there it goes and we do see mating
three
um given out by the evaluation part
there's only one move for white here
which is
king to c2 the king's going back on his
walk um how many moves has the king
played in this game so far
i don't want to know man travel the
world in the seven seas
all right is thor gonna go to take all
of connor's pit
connors i almost had pants i mean say
pawns
but the real question is does the
mountain eat pants too
yes exactly we're asking you a question
he was eating his mic yesterday i mean
he was he was blessed
yeah he wasn't stacking on his typical
protein stuff this game it has to make
up for it
all right well there's going to be
unfortunately made in one coming up
there we have it very good technique and
resounding 2-0 victory for half thor
all right and that will be game for
conor today
well you know i'm not disappointed in
conor's play i did see progress
absolutely coach is not mad that's and
it was yeah
so winning was never an option there's
light at the end of the tunnel
exactly for somebody who's just started
very impressive but of course thor
doing you know diligent and uh just
proved himself superior
well um best of luck to both of the
players
and all right indeed so we will probably
take a small break uh before the second
matchup and catch our own breasts
all right before wagga and austin
all right
[Music]
unlucky james you shared too much
information
sure i also i also vented right on to
bella it was very
why did you actually witness she was
doing a salad
look guys i just woke up guys it's too
strong
yeah point five
one is what it is there we go there we
go
oh yeah oh my god this is just fine one
point two five was
way 100 i'm trying to go fast oh man
don't leave me [__] crewmate man
purple white pink
orange uh purple white pink green
i'm dead i think and he tried it
looks really bad doesn't it doesn't it
it does look really bad yeah
it looks really bad bro uh bodies and
communications and hopelessness is
coming out of the room
and i'm going into the room um
wait wait wait i want to say this before
we go any further i definitely think
that dean is clear i'm pretty sure he
was doing weapons i'm pretty sure
like eighty percent sure yep
wait wait wait wait wait wait i need
that james where'd you go over there a
minute
um i'm in electrical right now no you're
not
that is so wrong i'm doing the spinny
circles in electrical this is the throat
okay
maybe he is i was pre-jacking lights
i didn't check the back you're pretty
what what i was trying to do i was
pre-jacking the lights just like when
they went off i was there
ejaculating
i watched people do the i watched people
do tasks as usual but i've been top top
right and bottom
so are we going to vote hopeless off
this or no
so this is what this is what i know okay
i watched dean
in front of the body uh the body's in
front of a communications room uh dean
says that he saw hopeless but i'm
pretty sure i saw dean doing weapons
although we can't be sure because you
know no confirmation's on
i'm down to vote hopeless with with dean
here yeah and it depends on this right
about bella here
and we're back of course with half thor
and connor how are you guys feeling
today feeling good
yeah yeah same same pretty good thank
you how are you guys
watching yeah well congratulations to
you half thor uh but we noticed that you
you seem to be disappointed
at some moments despite being up a lot
of pieces um
what are your thoughts on on how you
played and what was the origins of those
head shakes
when you were up like the queen in four
pieces
[Laughter]
yeah i mean i mean overall obviously i'm
i'm super happy
you know witness a win and now i'm
through to the championship show at
least to the next next round you know
so i'm pleased with that but i did some
blenders and
always when you do blenders when you're
acting fast
because you're just like moving pieces
fast you're not looking at
all the pieces and when i blend it like
that it it it does annoy me so
there were a few moments where i removed
pieces too
fast and i was not very happy with
myself
oh so i like that you know that's
dedication
high expectations for himself yeah same
hey connor you actually i did see a lot
of improvement today i was not
disappointed in your games i have to
tell you
thanks coach but we do have a lot more
progress to make
did you you were preparing right a
little bit before
uh yeah i did a little bit i took one i
clicked the lesson page
on the chess thing and then the voice
started teaching me how to open the game
well that's oh yeah you had an opening i
mean last game we had an opening so
progress was being made impressive in
the second game oh the second
yeah the first one i just kept doing
what thor was doing
we didn't know we couldn't tell at all
really
hope i'd get in the head yeah just just
make the mirror moves right
right yeah the problem is running into a
check eventually
yeah it was a it was a little bit rough
that first game but
it's great seeing you improve it's great
seeing you you know work on your chest
um and have improvements every single
game quite literally
yeah maybe we could go over that second
game because conor actually got to a
winning position which is
very funny uh um
right before yeah right so move
eight like this was all fantastic
definitely i
up here you yeah you blocked the queen
you know
from from losing your queen and here you
could have played g4
which attacks your opponent's bishop
forces uh thor's bishop to move back of
course and then you've got
h5 hitting that bishop and it's trapped
over here on g6 nothing no squares left
for the bishop
so knight g5 we were impressed that as
well um
so elements of you know definitely
positive elements but
thor your your technique in the second
game was basically flawless
um and despite your high expectations we
were actually impressed like all your
pieces in the game and that was well
done
thank you guys i appreciate that
i've been yeah i've been i've been i've
been trying to work on my game obviously
i've been trying to practice a lot
um and actually i did not play
a one game today because i feel like
lately i've been playing so much i've
been
i don't know i feel like i'm playing
like two months i've been actually
going backwards i'm not sure why that is
happening but like
today i just took a day off from chess
and came in fresh and i was i was happy
with my games
yeah it's okay that that always happens
you know when you play a lot and then
you your mind kind of gets
foggy but it's great to hear that today
you're feeling good about it so
absolutely
yeah chess is just like your strength
training you know sometimes
we need off days building big brain
muscles
connor right after thank you to both of
you we had a lot of fun watching well
done congratulations
well connor half thor a worthy
competition indeed but half thor
reigns supreme in the ends that was
very very clean from hawthorne of course
we wish the best of luck to both players
uh moving forward
all right and we will be taking a quick
break
before the next match um
between you know wagga
vs austin um a very similar matchup to
what we just saw
but
you honestly never know like a lot of
things could happen nerves could happen
austin you know he'll come and clutch
i'm sure
yeah absolutely well we'll be right back
and we'll have that much for you coming
up shortly
might be top right because i just saw
james on the camera and i thought he was
the killer
i didn't see him i feel like yeti yeti
where were you
i was in the navigation room doing the
download i didn't confirm that i
actually
got some info here so there was a ton of
people in electrical
yeah came out and went right i remember
that i remember
trump i believe went left yeah
uh i was in lights i did the card swipe
in admin i was one of the people that
jacked up lights
uh then i went to do shields uh i did
navigation
download and now i'm in o2 i i i
i have a strong feeling it's helpless
i feel like as well i mean
yeti downloading on navigation we're
mostly
just
look at the skippers look at him dude
look at the skippers
all right
green red
uh why your team shows complexity
because i am streaming for team
complexity
uh all right i'm gonna go and get my
glasses i got my orange juice which
you know anna told me that that's that's
what uh
that's what magnus had as uh as his
drink of choice for all tournaments when
he was young
very important i'll do the same i'm
young in chess
i'll have orange juice
[Music]
big fluffy
come here kitty no no no you don't go
there's no water for you i'm sorry
she always wants to drink water from a
cup you want to smell it's orange juice
i'm on i'm on it's game time
soon or what do they are looking at me
wait they're not looking at us are they
wait gracie don't run away all the
others have their pets say hi
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
pog gyms we just witnessed half
thor um defeating conor and
we have for you a really interesting
match coming up we don't know how close
it's going to be between wagamama and
austin but before we do that
uh we wanted to quickly remind you guys
about a couple of things first of all
the prizes these players these streamers
are competing for some very very serious
prizes as you can see
the winner takes home a cool 10 000
bucks but
second place gets 6 000 and a lot of
prizes
on the line win or lose in both the
championship and consolation brackets
so definitely a lot on the line and we
see the passion that these players are
putting in
and uh apart from that wanted to remind
uh you guys really quickly about
the schedule the upcoming schedule a lot
of really really interesting
matchups still to come we have wagamama
austin coming up after that we have the
long awaited matchup between hafu and
xqc
and tomorrow we have dog dog against qt
cinderella followed by
zextra against tf blade um shortly after
that so we've got interesting matchups
still to come um so we hope that
you've cleared off your schedule
tomorrow and will be joining us again
but for right now we have uh wagga mama
against austin
and andrea uh nemo thoughts on
what we're gonna see right now well you
know
the matches today do feel a little bit
one-sided in terms of rating but like we
always say
anything can happen honestly anything
could happen
uh wagamama has been doing a lot of
practice
which i was a little bit surprised by i
think we do
have to ask him um after how like
has he had experience with chess before
because i've seen him play a little bit
on stream and it's been
you know he's played well he's played
well i'm going to put it that way and i
was just really really surprised
honestly because
yeah so today's match is going to be
interesting
uh we will be seeing um some
some quality gameplay from both sides
and we did see
you know wagga mama you know prepping
his chest
with his cat and talking about drinking
orange juice
earlier so he's ready for this he's very
ready
yeah i definitely think wagga should be
in like a higher bracket
because i mean but we kind of expected
this before the match
but yeah i'm really curious what his
training was because
they thought he didn't have any chess
experience and now he's like one of the
leading players so of course paired up
with austin is not very fair but
it will indeed be entertaining he's he's
practicing often on the boarding like
nemo mentioned his orange juice magnus
carson drinks orange juice therefore so
does waga
therefore we got it guys the secret to
being good at chess is drinking orange
juice i hope you guys all have your
orange juice ready
um for for your next chess match or a
game
uh whenever it may be you know
absolutely fake and silly mate or magnus
still you make it well wagga mama
definitely yeah he he
he played the london system which is a
pretty advanced opening in the previous
uh matchup that i commented so he's he's
actually a very solid player
um and definitely knows what he's doing
and normally when you get
this kind of chest it's clear that
someone you know has quite a bit of
experience with chess
so i would also definitely be curious to
know what his training methods are and
you know how much experience he has now
what can
you ladies tell me about um austin you
think he's gonna
step it up here anything about him that
we should know
i genuinely don't know if he's had any
additional lessons
otherwise than his first one with my
sister where he learned the pieces and
discovered that there's a queen in chess
um if i remember the other other day
when we wanted to prep him against
conor he said he doesn't need practice
so i don't know if he changed that
attitude yet
but uh he's a very busy guy who knows
definitely he's got his own game show
and everything you know he's doing a lot
of
a lot of work let's see how much work he
has been putting into
um yeah
you know we never know he might he might
have hired a super gm in the back
helping him prepare um
yeah his strategy is off stream
preparation so no one can see it coming
exactly exactly precisely
he would not be the only person to do
off-stream preparation
so we're not gonna put it past him
absolutely not and uh
we're awaiting the match is he playing a
game already
he does like to trash talk
one of his matches he was talking to his
opponent but i don't think he was
talking to anybody
curious oh like we said he's going to
pretend that you know
he is he doesn't know what he's doing
and so
he has actually played i think a game
right now uh i just pulled it up
he's he's casually practicing right
before i like it and
okay of course it's good because he just
blundered and he just blended
i think i think this is what i think he
wants wagga mama to see this game
and and get lulled into a false sense
this can be an easy game
guess what this is where he pulls out
his prep
i don't want to be the one to point this
out but are we going to
talk about his rating i don't even know
how he managed to get it
you know the first time he was like oh
it's because my first games are odd
against alexander but now there's just
no excuse
anymore like come on austin
well it's a palindrome it's a nice 180
one you know it's a great one what's
another couple zero so
what 2181 2028 11
we could add one more zero to that the
numbers around
and you basically have magnus is rich
he's basically already 28. okay he says
staging yeah he's 2800 he's a magnus
level
right i think the lowest rating you
could achieve and over the board chase
is a hundred um in the
us chess uh system okay wait
i could have what's the lowest rating
you can get on chess.com because i
always got told it was 200 but yeah
i didn't think again he is breaking a
bit chest barriers
i think that if you go down below that
it maybe resets you know
wraps around to like 29 or what a 3 300.
if you get to the bottom of the list you
go back to the top you know yeah that's
a very
yeah maybe that is fascinating um
100 is at the lowest i think over the
board though yeah
i think also on chess.com can't get much
worse than this
[Music]
i don't know i don't know
that's funny well i guess to a non-chess
player oh my range is 181
wow that's that's pretty big so
i'm not sure i'm not sure yeah that even
two and a half so i don't even know if
that sounds
it was a good attempt it was it was um
all right
i might okay how about my rating is 2800
minus 2700 there you go
all right there we go that's perfect
we're there all right
we do have oh look george 85.
his his his rapid rating is 285 okay
100 points higher than his blitz rating
that's good okay and we have e45
let's see what opening wagon mama
chooses here he did play the london
previously so
probably going for something more
aggressive here
all right well we have we do have we do
have 903 coming out
um just hitting up the e5 pawn and i i
wonder if wagamama switched his opening
very specifically for this game against
austin
yeah i was also curious if he has any
traps planned or anything but
i think we all know which layers
okay well we didn't see that we
straightforward
never again yeah yeah that's true that's
true so we have the three night the
knight f6 would be the four nights here
which is of course uh standard fare
i not i don't like the fact that
austin's already thinking i mean knight
f6 here
just gotta develop your pieces sometimes
it's good to think sometimes i get
worried when someone's thinking it means
they're
overthinking and i don't wanna see
yeah he's very lost in his thoughts
or never mind maybe just because i know
he also he cares a lot about
his hair like he cannot play his game if
his hair is not prepared well so
who knows what he's thinking about oh i
think he's he's got his fingers running
through his hair i do think maybe he is
oh that is okay that's actually not that
bad
i i have to say in h3 my mama i'm so
very solid stopping
before we just give awesome no chance
for cats yeah
it's gonna be interesting because i
could have played very like defensively
this entire game or
um you know what i know about him that's
his style
prophylactic thinking you know a great
point because like many times also when
i get paid with players who are
drastically low rated than me you could
also just
play worse but go for cheaper tricks but
i have to say respect to wagger for
continue playing classy and defensive
and not going for cheap tricks even
though austin would most likely miss
them
i think austin is playing a little bit
like right now and wagga mama is
currently playing but more like hardpoke
he's
p3 you know putting the bishop on the
one diagonal
yeah this is this is some great thinking
you might see d3 here another
prophylactic move just defending it
for paul oh he plays all right mama
there goes
all right wagga just really does not
want to take the g5 pawn
he's playing a solid yeah he's playing
like actually
in developing everything yeah in ouaga's
previous games i was a little bit
disappointed that he wouldn't
find simple tactics like this like
really i was hoping he'd do more puzzles
before that but i guess he
maybe chose not to prepare against
austin i think i think waga isn't so
much about the tactics because i
like it yeah this match i saw him have
really good tactics but he
he tends to play it a lot more solid
than the other players
in park champ he's constantly thinking
about what his opponent could do
um you know just constantly preparing
moves you know for
future moves you might be doing that a
little bit too much in this game where
he's just like
yeah yeah i think austin was really
happy he casted his castle yeah he's
very funny accomplishment
all right but uh now that king position
manga s for sure yeah um
you know if if only knight takes e4
worked here unfortunately you do have
knight g takes e4 so there's no discover
attack in this position
he was thinking about it but then he
calculated that and decided not to
exactly
right so you got to chase maybe that
that night away with h6
oh okay good job austin this guy is is
is good
this guy is good just kicking the night
away knight has to come back
next move all right yeah austin
same with connor they have both made
some improvements in their games that
i'm seeing
austin's doing a little bit better
looking for his opponent's threats
yep and now just develop your pieces
develop that bishop
um he seems confident okay a6 and
immediately queen need to look at that
speed
hunting for that h6 spawn is wagga mama
this is a pivotal moment here
he's got to defend it with his king you
do not want to give that pawn away
and we might see bishop c1 if after
kingh7 just hitting that
creating that battery along this
diagonal hitting the h6 pawn
austin's gonna have a little bit of
difficulty defending his key position
i'm worried he's gonna go like b5 or
something yeah and tunnel vision the
queen's side
like wagga played that move so fast bros
and austin wasn't paying attention
you might just miss this threat exactly
that's a good point
but i do like how austin is is thinking
on every single move you know he he's
trying to
find out what what white wants to do and
you know
coming up with a response to that um
which was really good and i also wanted
to just mention i think guacamole has
hit
1800 on tactics
oh yeah yeah he did have that a few
rounds ago
crazy yeah and just harmonious
developing here
definitely smells some i think he senses
that there's danger here maybe he
doesn't definitely see exactly where
it's coming from but
he knows though exactly he does know
all right do we want to take a listen
into wagga mom and see what he's
thinking about
absolutely
all right i'm jamming
but i'm listening to what he's saying
you know he's really
putting all the words down yeah he
didn't like this
he didn't like this queen move he's
right he's thinking yeah
oh oh that's a creative way to defend h6
he tries
take you take i open up yeah i mean okay
i'm going dude yeah this is very
dangerous for you
this might be a fast game
[Music]
fortunately with the wreck open you do
have like he's looking for the fastest
way to end it
austin oh my rook
[Music]
um
all right some nice beats coming over
for guacamole i think he's feeling
confident about the game
yeah i really don't know where this
confidence is coming from honestly she's
rude at this point
and wagga we just missed every said that
this position looks awful so
the issue is that once queen takes on h6
there's going to be made down the h file
yeah there's not a lot you can honestly
do about it um
i mean you can try bishop g5 right now
55 would be a nice find it would
yeah he has to even looking at his board
he keeps speaking somewhere
we'll see last time he got stuck on the
defense so maybe
this time he'll he'll pull through but i
don't know
he doesn't seem quite as pumped that he
cancelled now yeah
yeah usually you don't really want to um
you know play g5 and then castle
it's it's sometimes okay to have this
palm push if your king is already on ha
you got your rook on g8 and your pawns
on h6 and you know you're you're
attacking white
but playing g5 and then castling
sometimes leads to positions like this
where
um you know your opponent starts
attacking your king and and it's a
little bit it gets a little bit
dangerous for you oh and then knight
before so he's discouraging white from
taking on h6 but of course white can
still capture that pawn and
that fork on c2 is a moot point and pogo
mama sees it immediately
yeah this is going to be made in one two
or three moves
yeah um very very difficult for black to
defend here
if there's any defense at all i'm i mean
knight takes c2 is one shot h4 yeah but
bishop
or otherwise it's your only defense for
black just cutting off the rook
um so you don't have checkmate with
queen h8 but
mm-hmm you know takes h4 it's going to
okay queen h7 first
but i have to say i'll have to say the
same thing oh oh
oh and we have never mind on the board
no finisher thought they have to say the
same thing for conor frost and they are
making progress because austin there was
still thinking ahead
you know he saw that threat he saw that
the queen would be leaving that square
and defended
whereas in his other games he wasn't
thinking moves ahead so there's still
progress being made
we see an immediate next game
coming from austin and wagamama with
austin as
white all right let's see what um
opening
austin's gonna bring out
yeah i'm very curious maybe you bring
the queen out to h5
we haven't seen too much of that that's
actually an interesting move
queen h5 here yeah i don't think i'm
serious it's actually not that bad
oh really oh okay guess what gm dania
has just commended everybody for playing
qh5 guess what
guess what i'm playing my entire next
tournament i'm a great influence
yeah the next olympian match queen of
tribe all right knight of three he's
developing well
okay he'll probably just play what
wagamama just played honestly
exactly that's exactly what he's doing
it's simple
he doesn't need to prepare his opening
but no g5 your last opponent did
wagga mama deviating from from g5 for
whatever reason
maybe the power of knows yeah he knows
that
that austin would play the same opening
he didn't like what happened
last game as black you know so he's
changing it up
maybe he'll go b3 though in the same
style
that would be pretty funny oh that would
be a good troll
okay now basically indirectly putting
pressure on that c
on that e pawn so you could take the
knight here and take the pawn on e5
right um but this position is also very
very complicated i
yeah do not imagine austin
uh liking that scenario too much he
plays bishop a4 this is in the style of
the spanish which is very interesting
too
if uh wagon mama plays b5 we have bishop
b3
uh we might get d3 from white next move
this will actually be
the d3 spanish okay austin's opening
seem pretty solid so far
and finally castle's in a position where
it's actually good
right and developing all his pieces this
is actually very impressive
yeah um opening play by austin solid
and he can develop his bishop to g4
pinning the knight
okay [__] should be seven very very um
you know i don't want to say passive but
very like solid moves
just just developing pieces normally
he's not faced by the position at all
he's gonna keep doing what he's doing
this is where it gets a little
complicated maybe austin should open up
his
dark square bishop with d3 or take the
knight even
to ruin black's pawn structure a little
bit a lot of good moves here
yeah yeah we'll see how far austin's
instincts take him in the opening
yeah i think d3 would be a great move
here or maybe even h3 just to stop any
future bishop g4
i do have to say that the spanish is my
favorite opening
so i'm pretty happy to see this coming
from austin
yeah very interesting positions always
coming out of the spanish
and um it's been around for very very
long time to one of the oldest openings
in existence
all right and austin deviates kind of
what i was expecting is going for some
tricks here
maybe not the best against opponents
such higher needed but
yeah i'm not sure where the trick is
because unfortunately the bishop is not
on this diagonal so you need
one more move for this to work not to
mention that blackened castle here
but you know i i do like this he he
he's doing something similar to what
waga
did last game and that worked out for
wagga mama so you know it might work out
for austin here as well
if you can't beat them join them yeah no
and that is one way that you learn is
you you
watch games and then you literally sort
of take ideas
and incorporate them into your games now
i'm a little bit worried that he's gonna
do something like take on f7 here
which is a slightly premature sacrifice
ever so slightly ever so slightly i'm
gonna vote he doesn't just because
wagamama did not
that's right i think we're gonna d3 i
think we're gonna get d3 that would be
that would be not bad what would be
really impressive is f4 which is not
necessarily that good of a move per se
but to open up the rook like that
yeah you might see the the rook good
plan of attack
yeah austin does like those type of rook
lifts though it is possible
all right so i mean there's a lot of
good moves here for white honestly um
knight g5 is really not that bad of a
move it might not do it too much right
now but you never know you never know
yeah but this is just a hard position to
play if you're not experienced because
you know nemo imagine how just undefined
it is and
how many options there it can be
overwhelming definitely one of the most
common ideas in the spanish is
of course well i mean d3 um
oh okay i like it nines i guess it's
it's well it's not not really losing a
piece because he does have a line but
yeah knight takes d5 here where you take
the knight and then also threaten knight
takes g5
i mean bishop takes you five sorry
you'll get it with e takes d5
and then after bishop takes there's he
takes c6 so
all calculated by austin yeah no okay
and it happens okay
it does now just take the knight that's
the important part games
i have to say even if it was not all
calculated
but good instinct centralizing his
knight um wagamama should have probably
actually moved his knight
over to d4 if austin takes on c6 he's in
perfectly good shape
yeah definitely he's going to be up but
does he realize
that that is what he needs to do well he
calculated it all right so
i'm sure he'll be able to see dude focus
yeah i hope he doesn't get distracted
that now there's some play happening on
the king side he
starts looking at the bishop and forgets
about his attack happens very often at
the beginner level
exactly yeah well and don't and the
important thing is not to take the
knight of course with the bishop because
black has a pawn on b7 and then you're
going to take that bishop
yes there are many obstacles in austin's
path here to find the best move
yeah um i mean if he goes over
his checks captures and threats he would
realize he has no checks here
his next best choice is a capture though
you know we're going to get there and
i see he got distracted by the king side
he looked at that bishop and thought he
has to defend something
very common error
h3 would have been a good move earlier
to stop bishop g4 but
yeah i'm not too sure what h3
was going to do but hey look he almost
had it he almost had a great exactly
right there and that's what counts yeah
i mean these are all
things i mean if you had like at least
one more lesson i don't think anyone
even talked him yet about forcing
moves and things like this so it just
needs a little bit more practice
yeah exactly and people who are like how
did how does he miss this is also
important to understand when you're not
experienced
things that other people take for
granted such as sensing that
not recapturing a piece is a big deal
that isn't necessarily something that's
intuitive right maybe you think that's
how important is a piece
all of that comes with experience so you
know let's cut him some slack he's
a great opening and uh he's up against
uh very very strong
yeah yeah one of the top players here
definitely i do also want to mention
that
um wagamama is is very very
you know high rated uh and like
when the way that this all got matched
up was we didn't really expect guacamole
to
sort of be this area and i think yeah
first like started packing he actually
hadn't practiced like at all
and then all of a sudden you know his he
just went on a
bus grind and then here we are so um
austin is putting up a great fight today
i guess um
it's uh except for the you know it's
it's really difficult to not to like
actually when you get one of these kind
of positions where your opponent took
your piece but you can't take back on
that piece the first instinct is to not
actually go look for another piece of
capture exactly so precisely
it's just there's a lot of um things
that you know
austin could improve on but of course
time constraints and everything he's a
very very busy man a lot of
accomplishments
yeah i mean even when i'm coaching
players like a thousand
points higher than austin i always have
to remind them sure
like pay attention to your opponent's
last move but what was your plan before
that
or you have to think two moves before so
it it's
very difficult yeah right the better you
become the more of the
the territory you know you kind of get
to know definitely
well yeah he took back on b3 um
i do like also how focused austin has
been throughout the whole
game yeah he's taking it seriously you
can tell
yeah even though he blunders but his
play is improving so
i think the most important part is
honestly not like you know
very specifically the play but the fact
that he's putting effort into it and
thinking about it really right
that helps you improve it's not so much
making the moves mindlessly but it's
it's really thinking about
that's what's cool right putting in the
right
thought processes and yeah i mean better
so rookie one i mean he's making a lot
of good moves here
he's quote-unquote only down a piece
that's you know so we'll see but
wagamama is just
so he's so solid and he's so disciplined
he's not he never rushes
yeah yeah just bringing the bishop out
i'm starting to think that wagamama
really likes fianchettos
he does he's putting that bishop on b7
or b2 like in the last game as well it's
just
yeah he likes this he's attacking the d5
phone
um austin can defend it right now with
c4 just not letting this
light square bishop open up which is
pretty important because otherwise this
diagonal could become really scary
right yeah they're going to be a
checkmate
there might be a checkmate delivered on
the g2 square hey mom okay queen
okay also defending the phone logan look
at him go look at that that this is a
great
great very good paying attention to his
opponent's threats
yep wow
um it's a okay queen f6 so why go mama
going for the queen trade
up simplifying
yeah the basics have been drilled really
well into guacamole
russian school of chess i mean you're
just going to jail boy you know
we wrap up
well he does play dota so
well i don't know much about dota do you
guys
um dota is quite popular
in like russia i mean it's popular all
around the world as well but yeah well
i do know that that uh one of the
strongest players in the grand master
yandapanushi from russia is also a big
uh
dota fan and i think he's very good at
it yes
okay he's very very good at it so yeah i
mean dota is
quite strategic pro player yep okay
bishop takes yeah
that yeah i think it's you know you
don't want to trade off the queen maybe
what white
could have done instead of queen e2 is
to play
weenie four but once again it's not an
easy move to make and you don't really
want to trade off the queen when you're
down a whole piece
i might make a prediction sorry guys no
you first did it all
i was just gonna say i think the game is
gonna end with a checkmate no it never
mind
g2 but he blocks it yeah i like it
i would say austin's like honestly doing
really well he he
saw that pawn was under attack this this
position is the reason why c4 was a
better defense
but he's he played one of his the two
best moves
just so hard to defend here
and eventually mama could blast through
with e4
yeah this would be a very very powerful
move um he's first prepping bishop h4
just forcing the rook to move away
or i'm a really fan of his focus he has
defend against every direct threat
okay another head on the right the rook
now has to go to f1
if we get bishop c4 they'll be d3
hopefully
um but right black's bishops are
really really powerful right now
slicing and dicing through white's
position and again
right direct threat and that that is
impressive we'll have to see if he finds
d3 if wagga mama plays bishop c4
that'd just be move after move where he
finds the best defensive move
i honestly think austin's playing a lot
better than than his rating
um and of course he's only probably
played like 20 games or something
overall
yeah so he's got so much potential just
not letting a single piece drop not not
you know giving up
you know what would be a really nice
move here queen captures pawn on b5
oh that'd be super cool yeah
um but i i like rookies
absolutely exactly get it out of there
now guacamole could resort
to the plan of getting the bishop to d5
and then eventually preparing e4
yeah bishop d5 would then stop okay
queen takes b5
will he find d3 oh
no no no no no
oh he was i mean he can only play solid
for so long a blinder just
yeah has to happen at some point i do
also think maybe it was the time you
know he's running away yeah he
played very fast that's true when he
takes his time
he finds the best defensive move but he
played that in like one second because
he's down
half his opponent's time yeah and now
the floor has opened up
it's king against the world here yeah a
really good move from black hero b
bishop takes f3 followed by
g takes f3 and then we have queen takes
f3 check and the king is
wide open let's see
yeah ty's got a lot of them
there's a lot of ways of course black
could play this but
okay e e4 also similar idea you want to
take or first white to take and then
you've got queen f1 just bring that
queen
okay before he likes he doesn't like to
sacrifice even a pawn when he's up
a queen and a beast he's not giving away
any puns now watch the game end in a
mate on g2 that would be funny
we might see a very very slow play from
waka here
he's not taking any chances now the one
thing he could miss
what if austin takes the pawn on a6 and
wagga mama pre-moves something and then
he makes him on the back
i want to see that i don't think wagon
will be premiering
because he's been so cautious very
methodical
queen g3 rook f4 okay he wants the
delivery mate on f1
yeah okay well he has that main idea
there's no way for white to really stop
it
what do you mean white's got plenty of
defensive resources yeah it's a big
threat
pieces okay and that's a good that's a
good
effort just giving them he prevents it
see
well austin hung on there for like
longer than i could have expected good
good defensive play overall not
disappointing this play again
yeah definitely not great opening and uh
admirable fight defending against
threats but wagamama is just
too strong yeah so once again proving
how good he is yeah for sure for sure um
and i do believe that wagamama is
going to be moving on soon and we'll be
taking a quick break and then coming
back
with the players for an interview
joe who are you around right now
everyone
names when you're around right now i
think i saw an eye in the name
of somebody going upwards from storage
that's a kill that he got
probably electrical is there anybody in
electrical i didn't see it i was going
to like
two bodies
no there's two bodies period but i would
like to know
who is with who right now i'm alone
no no i have the key i think james where
are you now
no i have the key no i'd say no [__] you
no
lights are off i'm with leo at bottom
storage and i i think he was coming from
the left
well i know he devoted you oh that's
coming from the photo
i was coming from the right because i
was that shields with the hopeless and
then i went towards bottom stories
yeah i i i actually agreed to that and
also
skip i went up
instead of following you guys at shields
and i was going down from my cafeteria
to storage
and i saw an eye in the name and
pressure it's james ireland
and he's going upwards from storage this
guy is
probably killing him you're talking to
me there's a body in electrical i'm
telling you or body close left side
i'm an electrical yeti
what one body top right does anyone know
where the bella's body is the pink one
no
i don't like because i'm an electrical
like there's nobody in there because i
didn't see a report
the last people i saw with conor were
goblin and hopeless
um but james could very well have gotten
hurt
yet he fell for the and bait it's it's
kind of yeti but i think i still think
it's kind of james though
nah i think it's james
[__] [__]
man why didn't they vote we need to take
gambles over this with these new
settings man
they gamble the game dude if they gamble
the game so i will win the game come on
man
oh who was there i didn't even take
notice
blue teal purple orange
i'm dead
i'm dead goodbye bye just kill me dude
[__] it
you tried it
orange still red
okay sammy you're going to tell me what
you did right there after uh being
electric tell me exactly where you went
i went um top left to camera
checked in on camera no no you saw me
like literally four seconds ago
okay
and we're back with both austin and
wagamama here
today how are you both feeling after
your games
wagon mama why don't you go first
i feel i feel pretty right i'm happy the
the group stage
is uh concluded now i'm so excited
yeah you know i i'd say you know for me
it's just uh i'm happy my score went up
i've never
lost so badly um felt like my first game
the nerves really got
you know in my in my head um you know uh
and uh but the second game i actually
was able to move around a little bit
without making too many errors so
good progress i felt yeah definitely uh
we have a like you know
andrea uh donna and i we were
really really impressed honestly with
how you were playing the second game
um feels like you really didn't let any
of your pieces slip
you you defended everything super well
all the way until until the end
yeah i i just need to i'm very defensive
because i'm just every time
i uh move a piece i'm like oh crap is it
going to get taken
um so i try to make moves to protect
them as opposed to thinking about how
can i
make a move to protect the piece while
also attacking my opponent
uh and that's sort of like some mental
gymnastics that
really hasn't been coming easy to me um
you know uh obviously i need more
practice uh
certainly but uh yeah i have to say
austin though like honestly
second game was probably one of your
best games you
you could see how seriously you were
taking the match whenever you'd attack
something you'd take all your time
you would find a defensive move your
your opening in the second game was
great you actually had like a
calculated line that would get you in a
slightly better position
just got a little bit distracted oh here
we have it on the board
um yeah so this we were so
so impressed yeah let's see austin what
do you think the best move here is yeah
i'm trying to look wait where where are
we at don't quit look on the chest
scream
i believe in you it's not a quiz it's
not a quiz but
was it the one when i moved my um what
was it the
look on the chess channel you can see i
think i think you're talking about the
um
the move where i moved my um the uh
was it like bishop the rook or the rock
you moved the rook pawn
it was move ten of that of the second
game yeah and i move
okay and i moved it all the way
diagonally right is that what you're
talking about
wait where look uh um i would go to the
chess channel and just look at that
board it's gonna be hard to find
yeah okay we need to look at the okay
where are we where are we on okay now
i'm looking at the channel okay
there you go okay
i didn't know this was a part of the
damn deal yeah i'm sorry it's a game
show
it's a game [__] okay
this is this is unfair i don't know what
the hell 1883
are you talking about where i moved uh
it from uh
yes you moved your you played h3 here
yes
but okay you had a really good movie big
puzzle tell me where i moved just tell
me where i did it because
i'm not in the game it's hard for me to
figure oh yes that was a brilliant move
i remember doing that yeah
um yeah you guys were most impressed
with that move
no no no yeah yes yes we were we were
impressed of it but there was something
better you could do yeah you had a
better move here oh i missed something
right yes um and i don't know that's why
i missed it
we can show this line yeah
all right okay so here here details
didn't mean to put you on the spot
yeah we're sorry we're sorry yeah yeah
i'm gonna be filing a complaint
i was trying to compliment you austin
because like
it was like a three move line where you
know it looks like you're losing a piece
but in the end you'd get a slightly
better so i wanted to compliment you on
the smooth line and just show you how
you could have
pulled through but instead i made you
nervous i'm sorry about it yeah
yeah it is nerve-wracking even doing
training on stream is nerve-racking with
a bunch of
uh very advanced chess players in the
chat bullying you while you're trying
i know right it's very difficult but
you're doing great austin you're making
progress
yeah so finally i'm gonna play against i
tried playing against the computer and
it was really difficult
so you did practice on your own time
huh so you can practice this i did but
it was it was very much cramming
practice okay i thought you did do
practice because your play improved
um are you thinking about planning
another lesson
yes i'm gonna plan another lesson um i'm
i've taken this personally for sure i'm
gonna i'm gonna really put
some more effort in well we can see that
you know today's match you definitely
put in a little bit of effort before and
it showed so you're on the right path
yeah absolutely keep your head up but
wagga
um congratulations to you what are some
of your sort of training methods
yeah that you've been using in the last
couple days that was uh
very solid very methodical play what is
the secret sauce uh
i mean i have to give a shout out to all
the people that i've been setting up
coaching sessions with and i would like
to ask you for one too
daniel um but yeah yeah
it's the welcoming chess community i
mean big shout out to anna rudolph i
think
we did a five and a half hour session um
wow
uh yeah i've really been taught so many
things and just trying to remember it
all
and i i can feel what austin you said
there's a lot of people in chat who are
way better than me
and when i practice i'm normally good at
the game that i play
i play dota normally i'm pretty
confident in that game
and then you go here and i i know that
you know
a lot of people in chat would do way
better than me and it's fun to
it's fun to be bad like actually feel
like so many people in chat yeah well
same with me like playing
flight simulator you know i'm really
good at flying planes you know
yeah uh and it's frustrating i can see
the chat's frustration because watching
like i tried to help miz kid fly
yesterday and i wanted to put my face
through the monitor you know and it's
difficult so i you know yeah but you
guys are both doing amazing and i have
to say
you know there there's always going to
be the people who
who will say stuff but it's as long as
you're you're enjoying it as long as
you're
like you know you feel like you're
making progress i think that's the most
important thing just
ignore everybody who says anything when
donya coaches me i get backseated so
hard
too so it just always happens
yeah you know but hey you know what it's
all right it's just chat
right exactly you don't let it get to
you don't pay too much attention to it
and there will always be supportive
people too so thank you yes there are
some there are supportive people there
too for sure um
also had another question for wagga mama
we were really curious
so i don't know if you've been asked
this before but so going
setting up the brackets uh you know
people thought you didn't have any
experience but
with how you're playing now like a top
player um
i think you told us a little bit about
your background in chess right but i was
curious to know more about it
so i've had interest for chess a lot
i've watched a lot of
uh youtube like i've said i've watched
so many different
content producers for chess uh i just
never really played it myself
much i i think after the 2018 world
championship daniel was
talking about how i watched that right
and um after
world championship i played probably 20
games and and that's basically my
experience
i stopped playing again uh and it didn't
i
definitely didn't do too well but i've
uh i've tried to learn lots
and i have to give a shout out to the
channel i've seen the most of is
definitely a
chess network on youtube uh generally so
you watched me a lot
yeah basically i mean i watched you play
uh i watched you played hannah
the other day oh yeah yeah we you were
in our chat yesterday that was really
exciting it made me happy to see
yeah no i mean it's awesome i i really
enjoy you just swag
you were truly truly we got to ch chat
after the game before and truly a class
act
he was very gracious so yeah i'm so
happy i got to play you dude
i mean i've actually seen yeah it's fun
what you're doing so
yeah thank you very much both of you are
impressive and
vlog i'd love to help you out in austin
as well i'm
quite impressed uh we're both of you are
so we'll set it up um
absolutely i'm not impressed with where
i'm at but
i do feel like i'm making progress
relatively speaking to my own person you
are
uh where i'm at so you know that's i'm
gonna be i'm gonna be happy with that
yeah you're doing great honestly you're
improving we saw so much
you know a lot of amazing gameplay and i
i do think you're underrated so
you know keep your head up we we
generally do
though you genuinely you're above 300
points well i know 284
at least i'm i was all the way down to
100 but i i started playing some
practice games and actually got my score
up a little bit
so yeah just more packages yeah and
it'll keep going up i was getting killed
by all the people in italy my god they
were killing me
well that'll end soon well yeah thank
you austin thank you
thank you guys for being great thank you
guys so much
see you take care take care bye
all right um
let's you know we're going to be
cheering on both wagamama
and austin um in their respective groups
and we're going to
take a quick look at the group standings
before we go on a break yeah so wagga
mama i mean in groupty jumping out on
top
of course after winning earlier today
he's trailing close behind
and um rip x in group a david pakman any
of the top
uh people any surprises here andrea uh
nemo
you can see here you know i i honestly
before
the whole pog jam thing wacka mama was
basically i i didn't even get any pock
jams training right but we've already
talked about this
um so i just wanted to highlight that
group c is looking
like a close fight so far you know we we
have david pakman
with nine points in group b we have
griffix with with eight points in group
a
um a lot of people are just with with
high leading points but group c
tomorrow is going to be their last day
we have um tf blade versus
sex road tomorrow as well as dog dog
versus cuny cinderella so that
is going to decide group c standings but
david pac-man with nine
wow and half oh we'll have a chance to
yeah play against xcc right now
after a break exactly she has a chance
to um catch uh mr pac-man so
big time match-up coming up for you guys
but first
we will take a very short break and when
we return the long-awaited matchup
between hafu and
xqc
[Music]
i wasn't uploading actually i was
watching and i'm pretty sure depp did it
but the only people on the stack were me
adept bell yeti and hopeless
hopelessness
and wandering's brain is so huge he
thinks me and bella were trying to
double kill in front of three other
people
[Music]
end up then if we're wrong about this
man stop [__] chasing my ass what is
wrong with you
[Music]
ah lights
okay trump you saw that right
uh detail what i'm supposed to please i
beg you guys you need to listen to me
okay
this is not a delusive episode okay sure
i
am upper right i'm just doing my [__]
bella is chasing the entire we're not
doing
[__] i wasn't chasing now she isn't
[__] and then we both go we
already voted we wait we both go into
navigation right you intro
i walk in the room i go back there's
trump
warding and bill isn't there she she's
literally she probably been
right in front of me i didn't what wait
i think she's still there
i was i'm literally there what the [__]
this is not a delusional episode look
stupid you can skip and see that i'm
right there
dude why do i always get poultry with
you
drunk
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm so confused
vented
[Music]
and we're back all right
so i first wanted to make a correction
i'm sorry guys i
i know i said that um david pakman has
nine
points but he actually has six okay so i
stand corrected there
um this next game between xqc and hoffo
is going to see who will be leading
in that group but we do already know who
is going through
in the championship bracket from some of
the groups
uh we can see grypics we can see
wagamama forsen as well as
offload julius and of course in the
constellation bracket
we already do have scissors xqc
connor austin easy with aces and
carson as well so lots of exciting
matches coming up ahead guys but still a
lot of slots to be filled
and this next game as well as tomorrow's
we'll be deciding who goes through to
which one
and as we take another quick look at the
standings
obviously consolation bracket going to
be tightly contested as well but we see
um the leaders that's also going to be
interesting to see these
incredibly strong players wagamama and
hafu fighting it out in the championship
bracket
uh andrea any predictions what do you
think that we're gonna see
as this heats up well not to be
biased or anything but in the
championship bracket
i say haku is gonna crush him
but i don't know man because it's so
it's so intense i'm really looking
forward to these games
and even the consolation bracket is so
close like
scissors versus for spinton um
all these players are very close to my
xqc as well and then obviously
connor and austin are going to battle it
again and they're very similar levels so
these matchups are really very close i i
can't even predict the consolation
bracket
definitely and you know austin has said
that he he's going to practice even more
and
of course all of these players too yeah
and connor is too so we do have lots of
exciting
um you know prep coming up as we move
forward and of course with like a little
bit of a break we'll see
we'll see how people do after they come
um
back from the break because the
quarterfinals will be starting on
september 2nd and that's not even to say
tomorrow there's actually going to be
one more day for the the group stage of
pogchamps um and we'll be seeing dog dog
play games cutie
dextro play games blade tomorrow which
is basically define
deciding group c so that's going to be
very exciting
guys group c as you guys can see
very close has not been decided yet
that's not exciting
for the finals too yeah definitely
definitely
but yeah i mean also easy with aces uh
we should point out put a
great fight against hafu so he'll have a
chance to uh to show his
improvement and strength in the
consolation practices as well i'm sure
we're all
we're all looking forward to that as
well yeah and
yeah the first two matches have been
started as daniel was saying
so you know how do you feel andrea who
who do you think is going to win between
xqc and scissors
um i will be i mean one important thing
here is to take consolation bracket just
as importantly as the beginning of the
event like
scissors i have lessons planned because
once again it is
close post in their same with connor so
i'll do lots of
coaching i hope to prepare scissors for
xqc as much as we can
all right gonna be taking it very
seriously
i like it andrea is a dedicated coach
yes and how do you like that
any you guys have any coaching sessions
planned um
i will hopefully we'll be um coaching tf
blade a little more except
my coaching with tia blade is a little
bit less
coaching a little bit more of me telling
him what to do and him
saying no to everything i told him
really i feel
like funny wow yeah it's a lot of me
yelling at him and just i'm not
listening to me
russian coaching school you know student
is bad but then students succeed
it all comes back to the russians it
always
yeah it does in the end it does but yeah
i've been doing some sessions with hoffo
of course and
hopefully i'll get a chance to coach
obama in in austin as well um
it's really a pleasure because of how
quickly they learn and we mentioned that
you know all of these matches coming up
but the way that these players are
grinding like
one day is a lot and they can do a lot
in one session so
definitely i'm greatly looking forward
to this heating up into the sessions
that i'm going to have
yeah i do want to mention that um you
know andrea and i have
and i think donnie as well have all
coach hafu so hafu's getting
insane prep done she's she's you know
she's so dedicated and
and it's great and you know um so let's
do a quick listen in
over there i wanted to mention for ha ha
like she's insane today after her match
against xqc
she has a lesson planned with me like in
my tournament games once i'm done with
the tournament game
i'm done i'm taking a break always
grinding incredible true
let's see she's doing some puzzles
see how her puzzles are going she's on
or is she playing
i think she's playing actually i think
she's playing oh oh sorry i don't know i
think these are puzzles
she's got a nice position yeah yeah
snapping off the rook here i i do like
that
she has oh just three minor pieces
that's almost a whole queen there
pretty much as a whole queen what's up
just do something
and we did work on some end games uh two
days ago so
maybe that'll come in handy although i
think she has just enough to win this
one
she's not playing with increments though
so i mean 64 seconds
sure she's up a lot of material but yeah
her time is oh she's
she's simplifying this is a really nice
location a fantastic stack
yeah just creating that past pawn like a
pro
and why one by resignation yeah i'm just
i'm trading all my pieces for this one
yeah let's do that do it okay you have
to look inside the laboratory
just five minutes ago he was playing
among us so now all of a sudden
once he's on the chess channel i had it
well sometimes it's good to rest your
eyes rest your brain and you're coming
fresh
you know multiple then he goes over and
then i block it then i get mine up
oh yeah okay whatever oh but he is also
coming in with some good endgame stress
oh i think this is a tactic whatever
dude oh oh yeah he's practicing his
tactics which is
which is good you know um definitely
something that
it's very useful in chess just to know
these patterns so like you know
we did see him play a fair bit of among
us in
like three hours as we were doing
he seems a garbage bit distracted yeah i
think we lost chad i think it's over
but we should also not discount the fact
that he did participate in pogchamps
when even though he's streamed they're
used to broadcast in 2000
the butterflies in the stomach can still
start so he has that experience
under his belt he's he's done chess for
a long time
anyway much love excuse me so glad
rose yeah
all types of different preparations yeah
there you know there are many many ways
you can prepare for for chesmas honestly
i'm not gonna lie some of the best
preparation for chess that i've done
is not playing chess because burning out
is real it's real and you know we've
known that hafu has actually talked
about this on twitter and all that you
know just
just how she feels about training so
much and
sometimes she feels like the results
aren't coming so there's a lot of
different ways you can go about
preparation
and well we'll see what happens now but
of course
the more time you usually spend in a
game i don't know if this applies to you
and andrea or donya but
usually the more time you spend in a
game the the better
your results will be but yeah typically
that trend is correct definitely
definitely now you want to be rested you
want to get good sleep and all that
stuff is very very important for chess
but
yeah i agree in general the more
training you put in
the results are going to show definitely
but
there is of course a certain like i
don't want to say limit but there is a
cap
to how much you can do without being
super burnt out
and yeah of course hafu is very
very you know she's she's done a lot of
game grinds before so she's experienced
yeah
but it's going to be interesting they're
both like
machines i mean xcc doesn't he's
streaming every day
so clearly he manages his burnout was
just streaming in general so
they can handle it in chess they're very
prepared yep
it's going to be a lot of fun
for sure this matchup is going to be
interesting i'm looking forward to that
i'm excited
definitely and we saw xkc play i saw me
play really really well
um the other day against david pakman
honestly he was defending everything
super well so he can calculate we know
that he can calculate he can find stuff
when he's locked in he's he's dangerous
and he's aggressive so
this is you know and hafu is very
respectful toward her opponent so we
know that she definitely is not going to
consider this an easy victory
uh but but this is definitely going to
be very you know
entertaining match-up
yeah two great contestants here
definitely and uh
you know we're just here waiting for for
the rounds to start
at in exactly yeah i think that's
half who's ready because she hasn't
started anything new xqc continues his
tactic
grinding yeah just getting some last
minute warming up that brain which is
also really good
very important absolutely yeah i used to
do like
um like 50 checkmates and ones or
whatever before my game started just
like you know get your
your mind started for a tournament uh i
feel like that's really important
all the time it may be more like a
you know a mental thing but definitely
like before i would go into any
tournament i'd always do like 10 minutes
of puzzles right before
yeah like put away your phone too that's
great that was very important for me
but like warming up your brain before a
chest match definitely helps
absolutely and i've tried both
strategies i've tried not doing any
chest the day before
i've tried doing chest 12 hours the day
before a tournament and i found that
as we discussed uh the sweet spot is
somewhere in the middle do some puzzles
but rest your eyes from screens you know
just get your sleep
and uh you know whatever it is that
works whether it's meditation or
nutritious food orange juice we've
discussed that as well
yeah whatever it is drink your orange
juice it'd be like magnus carlsen
exactly that could be an interesting
tagline
yeah no imagine imagine like an
orange juice company marketing to just
chess flares i was just gonna say that
watching like chess players start
getting sponsored by orange juice
all right all right guys tropicana i'm
waiting for my sponsorship
there's science that backs it up big
play like yeah play like magnus that
would be the tag line
that's pretty it's short and sweet and
um well
it seems that half was zeroing in xqc
getting those last couple puzzles in
all right i have one minute until their
match
and we'll definitely be listening into
both players they're
vocal you know they get into it so
that's going to be interesting as well
watch their thought process as the
wheels turning in their brain as the
game
heats up definitely yeah yeah say that
hafu has very very good explanations for
the move she plays as well
she's very very you know just logical
logical player
it's truly amazing to see her stream
chess and watch her play chess
yeah this is probably one of my favorite
matchups
not and not because the level is so
close but
watching them like they both have what
makes their stream so good is
pretty opposite uh you know like chaotic
and entertaining
is so focused and logical and serious so
watching them will be an interesting
contrast
but it's beautiful in its own way and
that's you know exactly
in chess you get the same thing you can
have different styles
um and you can succeed with different
styles and beautiful
beautiful metaphor oh well i
need to cry a little bit
just think think about the russians
danya yeah yeah i think about the
relationships
i know okay okay yeah you're coaches
right
exactly exactly just make sure they're
not listening on this
definitely gotten some verbal verbal
beatings uh after some lessons
but that would make you cry too just not
not in the uh
teary-eyed way yeah right before the
game starts i'll give a quick example
when i became a grandmaster which was
like the ultimate accomplishment
um i had a russian coach back then with
whom i worked for many years
so i i logged on to my email i send
everybody emails i became a gm
and i sent him a skype message you know
i have a gm i put 10 exclamation marks
and he says okay and then he disconnects
from skype
that's and okay is like not good enough
honestly i you know but that's also the
same
uh your russian gm's like your russian
coaches are
truly amazing because i remember when i
played in the women's world
championships and i got knocked out
he was pretty sure my coach was more sad
than i was and i was pretty sad
right no they care they do care in their
own way i do want to say that
i think again the best is somewhere in
the middle you want to be encouraging
and um i'm certainly encouraged watching
these competitors
put themselves into the chess world and
uh you know it's not
easy to start from square zero
especially for some of these streams who
are so good at what they do
um so it's really uh hats off and and i
greatly greatly admire uh both of these
competitors and everybody in the
tournament so
it seems that the game is officially
underway here we go buckle
up the seat belts xpc quickly uh did a
hairstyle before
jeff you guys watched that hair clip
that was interesting
good luck charm right there and we see
e4
and xqc taking his time on move one 30
seconds spent and finally going e5
all right i like this we're going to
see some solid opening play um
with 96 bishop c4 all right this is
actually what i have showed hafu
so i do like this opening i do like it a
lot um well my
i i've showed her both bishop d5 and
bishop c4 efficiency first italian
um followed we might say c3d3 hafu is a
very principal player so we might see
some opening theory coming from her
actually
she wants to learn the main lines i'm
curious if xvc is already a little bit
lost enough we could listen
in because he's drawing some uh
suspicious
arrows is opening thoughtful let's see
what's going on a fan of this
thing i don't know i think he's uh
scared of the fried liver thing
he's really taking his time here
will carry the fried liver though
pride liver or not this is the real
question shaq what do you guys think
i lost a lot of time here this is really
bad i can come back though i can come
back
okay at least he's aware of his
time it's okay eggness i need to do
quick moves here that are pretty good
or i can set up a foundation for for the
future setting up the foundation of the
future could be pretty good too
spending a lot of time early to have a
good game plan and then later on
executing it by gaining time and having
in the run up thinking
like two rounds of thinking one round
i'm definitely deciding whether to play
the fred lover
yeah they're both oh she does it
i like that impressive will xqc know
about d5
he was looking at it that's nearly
checkmate isn't it
that would be pretty much checkmates
no it's pretty much the only move here
that's the issue yeah unfortunately the
fried liver is one of those openings
don't know how to play
to defend it that's not that bad
actually queenie sam but it is
i have to take one when he does it
he's queen
where's the bang knight f7 is the boom
yeah yeah that is not a boom that we
want it's black
yeah it takes juicer takes juice takes
jesus that's pretty good yes thank god
he found it
oh my gosh
but knight takes d5 there's a very
famous trap where white takes on f7
will hafu know it yeah the move here is
actually
not 1965 surprisingly from black it's
knight a5 of course very difficult move
to find once again oh
and he plays knight takes about okay
yeah
like there isn't this there's nothing
natural
believe it or not and now i get a
crossfire
but knight takes f7 is a very dangerous
night sacrifice
i'm in a good spot yeah
you don't know what it's very hard to
see i'm not sure if hafu has
actually closely checked the fry lever
because she
i feel like what she did for this game
against xqc was a little bit more on the
side of playing for a trick out of the
opening
um because i do know that she plays you
know the italian and all that stuff so
um
i i'm actually with also the time she's
spending i'm not too certain that she
knows the knight takes f7 move of course
that's not to say she won't be able to
find it over the board it's just
not the simplest of moves to make
other good move is to play d3 here
keeping that knight on g5
very solid solid move yeah
d3 is is is good because you know
for for beginner of course oh queen of
three is really interesting
yeah hitting that eval bar took a big
yes because of queen
takes g5 which you know
queen f3 does unfortunately leave the
knight hanging on g5
but the knight on d5 is also hanging so
it's not the end
of the world for white will be
threatening check
definitely please he is familiar with
that particular threat though
he knows it he knows it very very well
[Music]
well this is you know if they get into
this position
um hafu still has very very good chances
but you know that's not to say black's
position is
it's not like you know completely fine
now um just because of that hanging
knight on g5
so what do you think sorry go ahead no
no i was just bishop e6 or queen takes
g5
both natural looking moves xqc does look
for
captures and checks though so i do think
queen takes g5 is very very possible
from xqc
andrea what's your prediction i honestly
have no idea because i was getting
distracted by his camera because he's
like
yelling and hitting himself and like all
these reactions i have no idea what to
expect of xqc's move here
the wooden shield has been set up so he
doesn't take the freedom
he's being honest he's he's playing it
safe um
i think this works out okay
yeah just defending the pawn defending
the knight
it's it's a very solid move i think
avoiding complications for him was smart
especially because he's lower on time
yeah the thing about hafu is also that
she actually does
spend quite a lot of time she's from
from my experience with coaching her she
does get into time trouble
fair bit so like xqc said that when we
did our listening
he is um you know setting this up for
the future so
all right bishop takes d5 not not a
great move because now
that bishop on c4 was a really good one
an xpc can recapture with his bishop
attacking the queen who should have
taken the bishop ruining black spawn
structure instead now x you see
definitely with the advantage
if he plays right and i think
oh yeah do we want to do another
listening yeah
absolutely this is a big moment
that's gotta be the thing immediately
that's question mark question mark he
realized that white took a knight though
he
yeah that takes two i guess he didn't
take that blunt and then what are you
gonna do
this no if you can't no you're not gonna
do that okay the problem with queen
takes g5 is that there's bishop takes
um
[Music]
oh my god he had a winning position oh
no
right he didn't see quickly
i said moment here
she's done it yep
but now i don't think she's gonna give
him another chance
the problem is you take the bishop white
takes and wins the rook with a fork
[Music]
i don't think that xqc realized that
there was bishop takes c6 after queen
hd5
um yeah this is this is going to be a
little bit
scary now for black he had he had that
one chance to play
you know bishop takes yeah i think what
happened in his thought process is
he didn't see uh knight g5 hitting the
first time it was realized that like one
move later
and that's what distracted him from the
center
yeah yep and it's yeah andre you talked
about this earlier that's just something
that happened sometimes yeah and had he
taken on d5 now of course the game would
have continued but
a very big initiative there for fcc so
he's definitely going to analyze this
detect his mistakes and come back better
next time but
what a fascinating opening for sure
it's one of those things where it's like
you're not really certain
um well for hoffa's kids right she's not
very certain about this opening because
she didn't prepare it
she thought it was like a trick that she
could play and then she got caught a
little bit unaware
um when black you know made made some
good moves
yeah it's pretty funny how flu has not
said a single word
this entire game she's that focus that's
what i've not seen her open her mouth
once
yeah we are watching her on our stage
it's it's not muted
she is just nodding she's very very calm
and collected i think
even when she knows she's winning she
still stays
very serious his threats to check me
yeah
i think he's realizing now he did not
find the winning move
yeah but you know it's it's it's good
he he he realized that if b takes c6 he
would have lost the
whole an entire rook right so this is
this is putting um
you know a bandage on the wound yes
although the bleeding does continue
after queen takes f7 check up a piece
with interest for white
some chances remaining for black excuse
he's got to make his king safe here
but hafu is kind of like a castle very
good technique
oh she's staying defensive
i guess she keeps the pawns forked so
she will still win and i could keep
attacking here
or here but consider oh
she i just
yeah that's not bad at all i like your
safe play like she's already
very in a winning position so might as
well be safe not allow anything
indeed definitely um
i mean most of the moves here are you
know
better for white just because she does
have an extra extra piece sorry
and d4 another excellent move exposing
look at that developing the bishop
attacking the queen
you'll definitely see this queen attack
he pointed out earlier in his thoughts
um and you know black's king being the
center of the board is very
uncomfortable very very uncomfortable
for black you know this whole opening
was just
quite unfortunate because it's like like
we said before right like
you know coming out the opening for
beginners is really important because
you can be either winning or losing
yeah indeed yeah exactly what happened
and xqc just did not win the coin toss
for this one he found
d5 on demand very impressive but just
didn't quite manage the task after that
definitely and uh you know hoffa didn't
make the best
choices exactly either but it was just
you know
who makes that you know last blunder or
makes that last great move right that's
what the dictates the
incoming out of the opening as the chess
expression goes the
the one who makes the second to last
mistake wins is one test master
that's a perfect description for this
game yeah
well his screen's under attack running
low on time too they've only played 11
moves but both players have spent
a lot of time we just get to show you
know or
you know maybe maybe maybe they have
prepared it but but i'm just
applying from the time usage here
neither player prepared this opening
completely unexpected and it just was
did not go in
his favor but he played some really
impressive moves
you want to go back to xqc side yeah
let's do it let's see what he's
struggling with here
i can't i'm done uh take take i
i'm playing so bad right now these moves
are so
these these these moves are so hard to
justify
he can't even blame himself it was like
opening theory movement
he really shouldn't be blaming himself
not like developing it um
i feel like a lot of these she's castle
and developing the house honestly
i'm just crawling my basement over
mm-hmm okay i like playing as black i'll
just fast white makes map thing positive
he has the next match
yeah they expect excellence of
themselves how good they are at what
they do
so it carries over exactly but yeah but
chess is
is very difficult team to play and then
so
that's right
okay that's good that's a good mentality
i'm gonna stretch
definitely never time to resign
then what
okay i i i'm bad i'm anyway
[Applause]
bang
i'm missing something here i'm still
minus three and i'm self-developed
good observations
[Music]
about to get finessed something's about
to happen i'm telling you dude
dude she's brewing something up
[Laughter]
she's brewing some sort of potion
said i don't like this position believe
it or not yeah i'm really curious to be
funny please switch
to her when he said she's ruined yeah i
think she
like grunted or something like that
nothing in mind yet
that's the story of chess both players
think the other is about to deliver
checkmate
exactly on it goes yeah
let's do a quick listen in on hafu's
side
one minute what is she brewing
yeah definitely not what xqc was
expecting
[Music]
i mean if he takes us it's a queen trade
uh xqc was seeming very defeated and she
does not
she's definitely not letting that
confidence get to her
she's definitely not yeah she doesn't
even look that happy about her position
i'm not gonna lie
i feel like she's down a piece like i
said about half thor it feels like
the opposite is true mm-hmm
wow the clocks are really ticking down
for xqc2
at 50 seconds already
g4 check very good move keeping that
extra pawn
i do have to say hafu's um blanket looks
really comfortable
yeah i'm actually thinking the same
thing
got the atmosphere set up
for full focus yeah you want to be
comfortable
that reminds me of time
oh that is no
oh
one is also good by the way that's a
really cool move does it work
bishop before when's the queen oh we
should search xpc i think he sees it
oh she
realizes it and that is going to do it
[Music]
okay we'll get our next game
he's got the white pieces bishop d6 is
the best he can do but you can
get half who can move the queens
yeah yeah sorry i'm gonna make you know
you would also move the queen yeah
yeah i would have moved the queen yes
okay she buttered it
okay i like that i like that yell from
him
oh
he wins a full well actually he wins an
exchange if you
move the night out
[Music]
definitely game is not over excuse me
you've seen
some good tactics
he's making good quick moves i'm
spending checkmate
i'm threatening checkmate
what bing bang
bap
exactly yeah he saw it that reaction
though
oh that was
close it's a close it was a good try
it's a good try though
but she's gotta make a a back rank
not to keep her back crank weak that's
important
yeah maybe h3 and look at that yep no
ice skater yep today no tricks
zero that's exactly what i expected from
her
doubling the rooks he's trying his best
but it's just too much material here
did i miss something
[Music]
it's just one of those positions he
definitely gave him his best effort
there but
hafu is not the type of player that will
throw a winning game
i mean she did do that in her first
round but now she's been taking it very
seriously like every threat
definitely um this is just one of those
times when it's like
well xqc is going to be most likely
losing this game but he has very good
chances in the next game to come back
you know he's seeing tactics
uh hafu has not been playing you know
perfect chess for anything
so we might also see hoff would be a
little bit more cautious with her
opening choice in the next game just
because this one
there were some good chances for ecstasy
at the opening yeah
i agree completely i mean she wants to
get out of the opening
in an equal position her middle games
her fundamentals are definitely better
but she knows that xcc can be dangerous
and tactics so i i agree
she's going to put the emphasis on solid
opening
get into a playable middle game and
sort of try to prove her superiority
there sure
and just with the fact that this game is
you know basically taking
the full time um 16 seconds to two
minutes they're both players are playing
very seriously
and it's it's really really encouraging
to see also xqc play this game out all
the way to the end right very very
you know principled he's great he's
doing great
he's really doing great i was happy as
the first time i saw a smile on hathu's
face
she looks so worried during the whole
game yeah must be your thinking face but
she did just
have a little smile so allowing allowing
herself to
wow a little bit of smile that's a
glimpse
imagine smiling during your game what's
that
ridiculous okay trading she knows she
knows her principles
very well now you can vacuum up the
pawns one
after the other all with check yeah i
mean what we saw from this game both
players
are very strong but both can miss like
the most
obvious well not too obvious moves but
they made the same type of blunder in
the beginning
yeah um i mean you know beginners will
always
misplay certain moves and it's just like
even if you don't know that opening even
for a stronger player like if you just
don't know about the fried liver
what are the chances you you know you
find
a 985 all the way all the way back right
um there is just really no spotting 95
this is the correct
yeah in this position and then theory
goes bishop b5
c6 and you take and this is just a
position where
uh white is up upon and black has
compensation but once again not
something that is very
likely to be known um
yeah and it happens even at the grand
master level i can confirm that
sometimes you get into an unfamiliar
position
and um if you don't know it
it can be hard to find a move on demand
um no matter how experienced you are
yeah one last prayer stay all made but
even that is far-fetched of course yeah
do you guys wanna have a peek in tofu
let's do that oh
we missed it it's like
a bullet just take it all take my knight
go ahead and
pro
no way she makes three queens right okay
she's gonna do it louder oh my god don't
stale mate
please don't steal me ha fu
she needs more confidence yeah i think
he's gonna win this game
[Laughter]
i'll draw the next one if you want
what what is wrong with me oh my god
okay it's fine
that's a good move actually king ju1
okay
i know she was so nervous like she knows
the latter day she has everything
she practices freaking out and you're
like no no no
no no
being so nervous is it's quite something
yeah i mean that's i i've talked about
that with her so many times like in our
last coaching session i said
it's gonna have a little bit more
confidence like don't be scared of ghost
threats like give yourself a little bit
more credit
but she's a very humble player
definitely
that's a great quality but you know i
mentioned this before
these streamers they're all used to
streaming before a huge audience but
chess
is a different kettle of fish you know
it can still cause those butterflies in
the shaking hands
oh excuse me is analyzing his game oh he
go go to stream real quick yup
look at that face of disbelief
now it would not have been over but it
would have been a very very strong
attack he's realizing he could have had
a win almost
but i could have won that
[Music]
he's actually a brilliant lion that he's
analyzing here
i think i understand it a little bit
deep but you know yeah
[Music]
yeah what's funny though also shows like
both hafu also
as soon as their game manages like oh do
i have time to analyze like right away
as soon as the game ends no matter the
result they want to analyze their game i
love that
very good qualities here indeed but they
gotta get ready for the next game
because it is starting any second now
with xqc being one what are we going to
see
in the opening and we see the french
from hafu yeah she does love the french
i remember yeah she learned this opening
she she's learned a lot of different
openings and she has like quite
honestly quite the arsenal of opening
prep now so
this will be interesting to see what she
does as she usually plays yep
e65 going for the french i think we
should shut up
the board all right let's do that
i'm not probably as familiar for xbc
bishop d3
i've seen him do this before what's
funny is i was watching his game with
tafu
i think it was against uh finton he did
this
similar thing and i told her it's not a
good strategy
the issue of this move is that it blocks
the c1 bishop from developing so it's
far from a disaster but it is you know a
little bit subpar
so we'll see if xcc can maybe fianchetto
you put that bishop on b2
something like that but a solid choice
indeed from hafu
yeah for sure um there is very little
that could go wrong this opening for
black
we might see e5 from xqc where just
pushing the knight back
might be a good idea but not not quite
certain
if xqc has played this kind of opening
before
probably more used to seeing e4e5 lines
so this will be really interesting too
and it's a very interesting strategy for
a relative beginner to play one of these
less common openings and catch their
opponent off guard
it also exposes you to more to different
types of structures
than just always playing e45 okay so
this bishop but this bishop d3 is not a
real opening though
it's well bishop d3 is a move if you
play
yeah two d4 on move two and then
bishop d3 is alive yeah yeah that is
great he just
missed that one move okay you made it
seem like it was
a line so as you speak i am looking this
i am actually going to check if this has
ever happened in the tournament game
before
and no let's see is bishop d3 novelty
it let's see it has been played
you will fall off your chairs over a
hundred times
oh why i'm actually not various types of
players
i'm not that surprised it's not that
honestly it doesn't look basically
it was first played in the year 1895 by
actually a very strong player
he's bringing out an ancient gem he
studied that game from 1895.
he did henry uh edward
oh one of the strongest players of the
19th century after human opening his
name played this move
so definitely you know bernie's was a
tactical player as far as i can remember
and xqc
you know is just imitating burn um
bernie's
otherwise it works the other way
this is this is this is a pretty decent
position for why i'm not gonna lie the
the queen is gonna be chilling on e4
there's no knight that can kick it out
of course he did give up one of the
bishops so hafu does have the pure
bishops but
not a significant advantage for either
side
eval does say it's very even believe it
or not even this position has occurred
in tournament practice four times
so we're following the famous game
machado against fernandez 1984.
which of course they have both steady
brazilian championship in 1984 they have
both studied this game extensively
i wouldn't pass i would have put it past
halfway to his name jeff said like
honestly she might have
all i know with all the preparation all
the grind she's done she might yeah
literally
yeah i wouldn't exactly and b4 is a
novelty i think novelty yeah well bishop
c5 is a novelty
okay bishop c5 novelty from hoffa where
are we
yeah one thing about playing against xqc
is always gonna take you out of the book
so no matter
how much opening preparation you do it
can't help you too much
you know that's actually something i've
discovered if you if you
are not certain about what you're doing
your opponent won't know either and
that's a winning strategy for me
honestly even if poker tournaments
actually b4 is a great move if he can
understand that he needs to put that
bishop on b2
along diagonal um who is it that likes
uh to put the bishop there was it um
yeah style um put that bishop in the
long diagonal threatened upon will he
see this move is the question
uh you're not don't sound too confident
you guys want to yeah let's listen let's
listen let's see it mm-hmm
[Music]
should be two incredible
this music
if i could or bishop a knight
bowl the view to assume anyone in this
chat could do bishop
that says some person
noah the grand lord
one thousand that's that's laughs i
think these are last games vlogs
[Music]
i don't know what that rant was but i
think someone in the chess.com chat
said that nobody can do that can she can
she do that
[Music]
good
yeah so he he anticipated that she could
castle in that position but
especially with the queen out it's i
think it is safer to go with
f6 and avoid any attack on g7
yeah this is like a very good way to
stop against any future attack like
andrea said so you know
hafu is is very very focused she she's
looking at the board yeah
just so interesting you know let's do a
quick listening for hafu as well i mean
she she's
quite quiet but yeah you know it's just
like there's so much
food oh man maybe i do this
and attack this pawn
so i can't get my pieces out right now
actually have so much pressure on me
crazy
what the hell is this move it's so good
[Music]
that's really good because i let him
fiancado and the tempo
that's so xpc opening
yeah xcc honestly has started this game
out really really
well yeah i mean you wouldn't expect it
with bishop d3 but it did turn out
following in the footsteps of harry
edwin
and uh if i do this he takes so i have
to tell about this first but then he's
going to go there
but it's interesting however
this could go this way oh that's so bad
just go here
in this position i think she could
castle she should she's starting to
block yeah otherwise she's just so
stressed
oh my god it's so slow but it stops as
night jumps
and allows me to develop
okay oh i do not feel good
there's an insane amount of pressure
what happened this game
i got wrecked
i think she's totally fine but yeah
she's she's already saying she's
arrested it's only the opening
what is he threatening yeah this move
doesn't actually accomplish that much if
she castles
pinned exactly to take the night
but i i think the castle okay
gross admirable that he sees this tactic
gosh yeah he has a good eye mercy xqc
i really like the amount of credit she's
giving her opponent like no matter the
rating difference
i think it's also very well deserved
this game because excuse me
playing good chess yes
like just just extremely like aggressive
i think
he's doing what he needs to do which is
what are his threats that's everything
honestly everything's worth
it right now if i go here
he's threatening this he's threatening
this
she's too scared i told her
ghost threats i said don't there's not
any real threats just
what does he do
this is scary
we just need a castle
and xqc is actually up on time now
yeah castle he's overthinking it
sometimes just going with your instinct
is the best thing you can do
definitely an overthinker gets the best
of us the castle he goes there
what if i do this oh my god
she's on the right track but she's
gotten into her own head though
not that c6 is bad but but her
hesitation might cost her i mean if she
makes too many weaknesses
it could get uh you know get dicey
yeah the time is definitely an issue
here
i can't think of it this time it's very
close i
i couldn't think of a good play for him
his knight can't go anywhere
he can't really take on this
excuse he has to move his knife he wants
a night sack
it's a very uncomfortable position but
um something i don't see a
threat let's see what he's thinking yeah
i'm a little bit worried that he's
taking this long maybe he's deciding
where to put the knight
dude what am i doing i need to play safe
i need stop thinking about
fancy strats i i it's not going to work
his observations are so cool this over
here
everything he does wrong
um
there's not many places to move here
bing bang
[Music]
i don't even know just get him out of
there dude
okay let's say i move this over here she
moves that over here
good calculation but he's gonna watch
[__] she takes
[Music]
terrible it's it's just terrible
interesting ideas they're both not happy
with their position and both of their
positions are fine
i know exactly they're they're both good
yeah they're overthinking just a little
bit
but like their main weakness like over
stressing themselves out
over thinking but they give me a pound
no i didn't i got this swinging back i'm
developed
decently well i think i don't know
there's important words of encouragement
you got to bring your
there's something that i'm not thinking
about too man this is what we like to
make sure this is still working
i could just back it up once and i can
move my queen over at once
[Music]
is
this is mesmerizing like i could just
watch them
[Music]
he really likes that e5 square that's
what i'm going to say
this there yep there we go that
this that is not worth sacrificing for
no this is not going to give me anywhere
i'm not sure why he likes the e5 square
so much
they both their thought process like
they're so abstract
in these ideas but here you should make
a move like can i slice free
in like seconds and save time
[Music]
i don't know if this is good to do
actually just to capture her facial
expression
wow where does it want to go
she has a free pawn man she's letting
him get here
if i take he comes out
i go here you can also do this
stops this but then his rook comes here
there's gonna be a time scramble folks
yeah buckle up
i'm i'm in my seat i'm on the edge of my
seat already
three minutes hey
there's a lot of my bishops ideas that
you know
i'm not quite sure where they're coming
from well
it's like two boxers and they're afraid
to throw the first punch there literally
we're walking around the ring and there
we go all right we have the first punch
we do
the first move yeah sorry go ahead he
must complete his development i was just
gonna say
try to get that attack going on black's
weak and center
all right c3 is going to be a very good
move
let us bring it back
all right these bishop trades are
probably going to work out
um actually in xqc's favorite just
because
you know simplified position he won't
have
a lot of material to lose everything's
so solid for him yeah he's way
developed he's developed way more than
hafu has
nice pawn structure yeah and that he's
six fun this week so he's definitely got
compensation for the pun but has to
castle quickly this andrea you pointed
this out this is where he needs to save
time
yep 94 very aggressive he keeps going
for it
i like the style of play centralizing
the knight attacking e6 hop has got to
defend that and she
will
push that pawn out she can trade queens
yeah here you can really see the effects
of the
uh hafu's one too many pawn moves not
the sexiest traits
of development i just need to get this
thing out of here
and if she would have saved back moves
like i need to be confident that i can
win
an end game and trade pieces
all right i don't want to take that
we need five moves because this creates
the double pawns
going to be a tough end game i mean hahu
is up the palm but
on the other hand she might be a little
bit more experienced with end games and
she's done some end game training but
xqc got to drop his knight back to f3
which he does attacking e5
the xqc has a better position but i
think overall she's a better end-game
player
so what will overweight itself here this
is true
white's advantage is not fast but
but it is quite significant yeah yeah
yeah will anybody
castle in this game though do you want
to play our best
now they're probably going to activate
their kings instead it's the right idea
but not quite the right move now e4 is
very strong
had xqc put his knight on c4 instead he
would have had a fork on d6 with his
knight
great well i do think that this e pawn
will be dropping
at some point regardless um just because
it's so difficult for her for
her um to defend it but you know knight
g5 might be interesting now
there is knight c5 um let's see where
xcc oh he does put his knight on g5 okay
so he's attacking both this is a good
move
um hoffa does have knight c5 which you
know defends both pawns but
still very very active position for
excuses tonight it's very
a very very quality game yeah
go ahead other doesn't say our devil's
pawns are a huge weakness and xcc has
pretty easy play like
castle put his rooks on the e file the
target is so
obvious for where he needs to attack
mm-hmm
well we'll still need to see is anybody
going to castle here what are your
predictions guys
i think no no because uh half was going
to put a king on e7 to defend the e4
they have six spot
xqc might castle actually she just
solved her pawn structure
you missed the the obvious weakness here
but i find not a great move she's
creating more weaknesses on those dark
squares xqc will try to put either a
rook or a knight there
but one minute on the clock oh this is
going to get tense folks
this is going to be a time scramble
you should be going after the bishop
which is this is trying to draw a shot
[Music]
[Applause]
that might be significant and he castles
there we go his quick place
doubling on that
a rook t3 wait what is he doing he
played a brilliant move here
blocking her pawn there now she can
easily double and he's staying on the
defensive side
yup it's not going to be easy to break
through but with 55 seconds this will be
hard to defend for xqc i can't just
play now rookie wins the pawn yep he
recognized it right away
with an accuracy and he says
[Music]
now breaks through taking on d2 this
gets very very dicey now
oh no the background noise
going to be unfortunately too strong i
think he's going to lose here
triple triple
[Music]
oh those double pawns i mean those uh
sorry pear pass balls could be dangerous
and hot food
okay yeah after
[Music]
come on i can do this
how do i make this work away
he's staying positive here
quietly pushing the pawns of the board
oh rook b7 would have been his last
chance there maybe
he stopped at least twice but now yeah
even
[Music]
oh he sees it awesome
it's going to be close though c4 g5 this
is that rook on b7 is stopping black's
king
from coming to the e7 yeah and if she
tries
to g3 check to take that g oh she's not
going for anyways
86 very good move forcing butt white
don't you give it up
yeah direct v8 has to play with v8
you must you know
[Music]
oh
giving xcc a draw oh that was
cute because he offered to drop it it
wasn't running out of time
a little bit now that she can relax and
of course
already qualifying into the bracket so
yeah that was definitely gracious
you know that was like one last hurrah
when he was like effort
he stacks his work tries to push it was
a good effort
all right um and we're going to have
break and i'll also take this time to
say
uh goodbye to chat andrea and daniel
will be doing the interview with xqc and
hawfu they both played amazing chess
today so i hope all of chat is giving
them
lots of energy and love
thank you nemo pleasure pleasure
commentating with you and uh
all right thank you for being a great
co-commentator see you later absolutely
see you guys well when we
also you kept your word said last game
you would accept the draw next game yeah
yeah i mean it doesn't affect my score
right
so whatever he played really well
he actually what was i supposed to do in
the early game i was
getting wrecked i got wrecked early
castling castling here feels so sketchy
oh
i just wanted to trade but then he kind
of helped me at the end
the ghosts it felt like pressure
you're telling me that you like my
position i can't believe this is even
i can't believe this this does not look
even if you look at this
would you really rather be black
yo thank you so much for the bits
sure
okay i think i'm joining the zoom call
[Music]
so
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
pogchamps we have just witnessed an
incredible match between xqc
and its hafu uh which itapo won
amazing games at tafu uh just
crushing it well congratulations to you
uh facing the very very top resistance
of xtc
through uh your thoughts on the match um
give us the blow by blow of how you felt
well the first game
i started studying the fraud liver but i
didn't get
too deep so i think i blundered but
apparently he didn't take advantage of
it i was analyzing it as we started the
next game
yeah you guys were actually both doing
the same analysis
after and i'm assuming you saw the
moment where xbc had
almost winning oh i didn't get there yet
but i will look it up with you
after yeah we'll be doing some another
coaching session after but yeah
and that was theory that neither of you
guys are familiar with and
had winning chances what's opening
i'll show you i'll show you my dad um
yeah that was kind of loose on my end
and then um
the second game he actually put me in so
much pressure
yeah i was in a really bad position it
felt i
i'm looking at the analysis and it said
that i was fine but it didn't feel that
way
because i couldn't move my queen size
queen side pieces
and it's suggesting i castle but i just
maybe
maybe in like a perfect play from that
point on after castling but it felt like
i couldn't move
i can't move the bishop because his
queen is hitting that pawn
and then i can't move the knight because
he can just push the pawn so then i
thought of you know prepping the knight
jump with
um what is it a6
yeah yeah a main thing for that
um for like what i told you before was
the ghost stress like like you said you
know
he was putting a lot of pressure on you
and constantly attacking but
computer says that he's not really much
better mostly just because his moves
were intimidating i'll show you
well i'll show you when we're doing a
coaching session um later unfortunately
you can't access the board right now
but it was just the main thing about the
ghost threats that we talked about
earlier like
you you you seem so stressed out that
game
which i mean his moves were intimidating
but all you got to do is castle like a
little bit early on
and you'd be okay it felt like if i
castled though because it wanted me to
castle
king's side and it felt like i couldn't
move my queen side pieces whereas
it felt like he could reroute his pieces
much easier and quick
quicker but that's why i didn't like
castling there right
practically it was easier to play uh to
play white there
yeah yeah yeah was actually quite solid
i mean it was really interesting um
pretty pretty instructive stuff yeah we
never played something like that i was
really happy when he traded
his knight for my light squared bishop i
was like yes it's dead
thank goodness and xcc with a very
finding very interesting idea of putting
that knight on d5
so both of you really enterprising uh
original chess throughout the match
we all know and admire him how hard you
have worked
uh throughout um but how do you sort of
avoid burnout
how do you manage the necessity to work
while at the same time
um you know keeping yourself refreshed
i mean i am the prize there's only a few
more days and
um i have really tough opponents ahead
hopefully plural
hopefully i can take that enforcement i
know there's a lot of boys and fans
but um oh yeah the chat he'll cheer him
on when it's not even his day to play
but don't let that intimidate you
nah i mean i know forsen he's super nice
and it'll be a really fun match
um but yeah he's scary i'm scared of it
he's like
one of the people i was scared of coming
into the tournament
and uh yeah we'll see how we do
wait forsen was one of the players you
were scared
okay i wanted to ask you because um oh i
think
is it and i think we've been we've been
joined by xtc
welcome hello and what's up guys
well congratulations on a very well
played match uh xqc and thank you for
joining us
um well we know the match didn't go your
way but could you talk us through some
of your
thoughts uh on these really interesting
games sure man
uh it feels really odd to be
congratulated when i lose um
when i was raised um you don't get a
participation award yeah the winner you
lose
so um it's a little bit odd but uh
uh i knew it was gonna be a tough match
yo and i didn't really prep for the
match up
and um i i had a couple blenders it
wasn't too bad it was pretty good
it was all right um also also
this is other words i live by uh if i
don't put in the effort i can't complain
about the results
and uh that's kind of the case here
that's a good attitude but i definitely
think you should give yourself
more credit like the second game i was
even thinking might go into armageddon
because
the opening so you have a weird strength
you didn't prepare any opening and we
could see
but like just those attacking moves you
were doing hafu was really feeling the
pressure
it wasn't until like the end game where
the tables really turned because that's
where her experience shines through
because she's played
so so many games probably more than i've
played in the last month but
until like the last few moves and then
game it was tied
very close position yeah you see i i'm
exploring chess
right and um lately
after playing optional a couple times
you know i'm still like discovering like
very
rudimentary uh uh things that you guys
are probably already doing chess but
because you're good you can see all
these things happening
yeah one of the i noticed it is like
sacrificing into a check into getting
something in so i
i kept putting my pieces up to look for
like a sneak attack she wouldn't see
like
just throwing a piece in there sacrifice
and getting another one
and i knew that if i did something she
could possibly miss it
and i kept trying to push that it's why
my pieces were always up and always
always like uh
going forward with them because that's
one of the concepts that i that i that i
saw or learned
so maybe there's other stuff that i
should uh yeah i would learn
yeah that concept oh daniel you first no
i was just very quickly going to say
that
xcc your move three in the french in the
second game that bishop move out
at first we thought it was it was
uncommon but we we noticed that it was
first played
over a hundred years ago by actually one
of the strongest 19th century players so
you followed in the footsteps and uh we
really appreciated the originality
um yeah andrea go ahead i was gonna say
we could definitely see those concepts
in play and they were paying off because
asu was spending so much time and even
though sometimes they were mostly ghost
threats it was definitely intimidating
play you just need to find to
balance it out with more defensive moves
that you can also play faster and save
your time on the clock
yeah i'm pretty bad late game too my
game is so bad
like um i feel like late game is
something that you kind of just get a
grasp of like over time we're playing
like a lot of like hundreds of games
you know we have to think about it that
much you kind of just you're able to you
know like like do it just by seeing it
uh and my game is so bad like um
i'm just moving pieces and like yeah my
pawns have to go up yeah you're going up
this guy over there
there's one up you're going yeah i mean
there was a moment when both of you were
you know thinking that the other had
this nefarious plan
up their sleeve but um yeah very very
interesting positions uh
indeed in both games there's so much
pressure in the second game
i i thought you were gonna take that one
yeah
um i thought i was getting somewhere
with that uh until i blundered the the
the rook but even then i think i think
it was already over but i i thought i
had it back
it's okay though yeah i didn't expect it
to be so
close i mean ha foo i i notice you also
don't really underestimate any of your
opponents but there's obviously a huge
rating gap
and the second game majority of the game
it was played equal on both sides
how did you feel about that food yeah i
mean he like did you expect good moves
and i actually thought he was going to
take it because
i couldn't move my queen side like i
said and i thought
i just thought it was over because it
felt like he could move his pieces very
freely and it felt like i couldn't at
all
so i think if he found you know one or
two more threats
he could have gotten there because
everything was kind of tight
well probably the biggest objective
chance uh was in that first game in that
really interesting line
where xcc had you taken that night and
you know as he found out after the game
it was a very strong attack
but you did find the move d5 which we
were very impressed by on demand
in an unfamiliar position so lots of
good moments for sure
hey man all right well i guess i'll
grind my way through the consolation
bracket or the losing bracket
and hopefully see some other people
there yeah you guys both have
very top chances in both of your
brackets so
we're looking forward to it absolutely
well
congratulations hafu and very well
played
gg honorable match of chess and also
hey sorry for uh is sending you guys up
last night
uh last morning uh evening whatever time
it was
[Music]
oh you made up for it with good play
exactly
thanks for being homeless thank you guys
all right bye after see you later bye
well what an honor to be joined by hafu
and xqc
andrea and very interesting match uh
indeed so what a day of chess what are
your sort of hot days eventful
day my hot take
is that is that what you asked her yeah
what's your
immediate reaction to today and what do
you think about the matches coming up
all i can say is you can't underestimate
anyone i definitely underestimate xqc i
thought ha foo would school him like
the games would be quickly in that
second game totally showed his
his full potential so i was very
impressed you know that rating doesn't
doesn't mean too much it doesn't and we
see people playing
way above their rating and grinding no
matter what their rating is as we take a
quick look
at the bracket we see the constellation
bracket and the championship racket
getting defined we see
amazing names in both wagamama winning
today half thor winning resoundingly as
well but
consolation bracket as we discussed
going to be
very very hotly contested easy with aces
fintan
playing a great match earlier against
often we saw austin today andrea you're
going to coach him up
we see that he's a quick learner he's
definitely going to impress
uh in the constellation bracket under
the able under your able tutelage
yes i have lots of coaching to do here
i'm gonna coach connor and austin
and hafu and scissors so i want everyone
to get the most of it here
absolutely well we come to the end of
an amazing day of matches and of course
uh pogchamps continues tomorrow with
more
fascinating matches as the battle heats
up
uh well andrea it was a pleasure
to commentate with you if you want to
finding find nemo we had to get that in
me they've been writing on that joke
or like over roasted coffee but uh andre
it was a pleasure
uh to commentate with you a fascinating
day and
we thank everyone uh tons and thousands
and thousands of people watching
and participating and cheering on these
amazing streamers
and participants and thanks for you
danya
well thank you andrea and we will uh see
you tomorrow
uh for another day of chess for now have
a great evening
stay safe and bye everyone see you guys
later
[Music]
foreign